[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il
ce soir nous écouterons ce que je viens
d'appeler dans la salle et vous
écouterez évidemment votre tête de liste
françois xavier bellamy puis pour
clôturer cette belle rencontre
nous aurons le président de notre
famille politique laurent wauquiez mais
en attendant je vous demande
d'accueillir le champion du bassin
d'arcachon yves foulon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
bon les amis quelle belle salle vraiment
vous faites honneur à cette belle
réunion à bordeaux il ya encore quelques
mois on nous disait a battu résigné
affaibli regardez vous regardez nous on
est uni nombreux et conquérant et une
petite confidence
ça faisait longtemps qu'on attendait ce
moment de se retrouver aussi nombreux à
bordeaux dans cette belle ville de la
nouvelle aquitaine quelle ambiance ce
soir pour recevoir évidemment nous avons
deux personnalités de très grande
qualité qui sont là avec nous et qu'on
va écouter dans un instant je voudrais
qu'on fasse innovation notre président
du mouvement laurent wauquiez merci
laurent merci
[Applaudissements]
merci laurent tu nous redonne espoir
dans notre mouvement
tu as cette volonté cette envie cet
engagement c'est détermination qu'on te
connaissais mais tu là mais maintenant
tu l'aimés ses qualités au service des
républicains et c'est un vrai bonheur de
t'avoir ce soir et de t'entendre dans
quelques instants
et on a aussi le plaisir l'honneur
d'accueillir notre brayons tête de liste
la révélation politique de l'année un
tonnerre d'applaudissements pour
françois-xavier bellamy
[Applaudissements]
alors au nom de nos deux personnalités
je veux remercier bien sûr l'ensemble
des parlementaires de toute la nouvelle
aquitaine qui sont ici parmi nous
députés sénateurs les maires les
conseillers régionaux les consignes des
parts mentaux tous les élus présents de
la nouvelle aquitaine qui viennent nous
entourer ce soir mais merci aussi aux
cadres de nantes revenant aux élus aux
militants conseillers nationaux à tous
ceux qui font un travail formidable au
quotidien pour faire vivre notre
mouvement politique merci bien sûr un
cpnt incarné par eddie puyjalon ou qui
est là parmi nous qui incarne cette
ruralité auxquels nous sommes attachés
ici en aquitaine
je pense aussi au nouveau centre qui
hélas incarné par notre candidate
girondine également sylvie trautmann qui
parmi nous et puis bien sûr le chouchou
de la nouvelle aquitaine et qui va
s'exprimer dans un instant guillaume
guérin premier adjoint
et les amis bien sûr qu'il est fébrile
et les 17 sur la lys dimanche prochain
pas celui-là l'autre après il est élu
député européen donc c'est bien sûr
qu'on va se bouger pour réussir ce tour
de l'or bien sûr que nous avons aussi
notre candidate de coeur tu le
comprendras laurent françois xavier
c'est hortense chartier notre jeune
candidate girondine qui est la chaire
l'auront tu peux le constater
toi qui le président de notre mouvement
l air dans toute la nouvelle aquitaine
et en gironde je peux en témoigner est
en ordre de bataille la gironde s'est
redressée l'éclaircie est enfin arrivé
je veux féliciter et remercier tous les
militants les sympathisants qui sont ici
ils se sont mobilisés tu vois cette
salle elle est plein c'est un succès et
nous sommes tout simplement prêt à
reconquérir le coeur des français et
incarner l'alternative à cette mauvaise
politique que mène le gouvernement de la
france parce qu'en fait cher ami depuis
deux ans est ce que la france va mieux
dans notre réalité les retraités
lourdement taxés pense que ça va plus
mal ça fait six mois qu'on allait gilet
jaune dans nos rues et dans l'eau ville
les fonctionnaires manifestaient encore
la semaine dernière les classes moyennes
considèrent que leur situation
économique et sociale s'est dégradée
les agriculteurs sont malheureux ils
sont désespérés les entrepreneurs ne se
sentent pas accompagné pour affronter la
mondialisation les élus que nous sommes
ici sont méprisés et bien une grande
partie de la france sont abandonnés et
les promesses du président de la
république de les rassure pas et en plus
on est confronté à la violence
permanents notamment à bordeaux dans nos
rues et à la montée incontrôlée de
l'immigration ça veut dire que tout va
mal et qu'il faut proposer d'autres
solutions et bien laurent avec le
mouvement tous les incarnent à ces
solutions est une cesse de les donner
aux français ils sont simples valoriser
le travail puisque l'assistanat redonner
du pouvoir d'achat en diminuant de 10 %
l'impôt sur le revenu pour tous les
français
supprimez de suite toutes les hausses de
fiscalité notamment la csg stopper
l'immigration de masse et retrouver
enfin de l'autorité un peu d'autorité
dans notre pays et pour financer ses
propositions tard cet aller simple tu ne
cesses de la donner aux français il faut
réduire les dépenses publiques c'est
exactement ce que ne veut pas faire
notre gouvernement
on en est là alors ce soir c'est de
l'europe qu'on va parler bien sûr cher
françois xavier
nous sommes heureux d'accueillir
sincèrement à bordeaux et tu as ici déjà
beaucoup d'amis dans cette belle région
de la nouvelle aquitaine ta personnalité
tu à geneston enthousiasme nous plaisent
et nous rassure ton analyse de la
situation européenne actuelle démontre
également la compétence en la matière
les propositions que tu portes avec ce
trio que laurent wauquiez a choisi toi
mais magna c'est vrai un road en jean et
bien sûr toute la liste et qui s'ils
démontrent qu'il ya un chemin européen
auquel nous ici nous sommes attachés et
tu as cette qualité extraordinaire que
goethe indiqué en début en début de
rencontre tu as su rassembler notre
famille politique qui en avait bien
besoin ça c'est fait et c'est admettre à
ton actif sous l'autorité de laurent
wauquiez ses amis françois-xavier
incarne un positionnement politique nous
apprécions que nous aimons il refuse
cette europe fédérale représenté par la
république en marche le parti socialiste
la gauche ou les verts
et il refuse cette europe du rejet du
repli qui est incarné par le
rassemblement national debout la france
et les insoumis en fait qui nous redonne
de l'espoir et nous croyons en l'avenir
grâce à toi
alors chers amis nous allons avoir
l'intervention de françois xavier et de
laurent nous l'attendons avec impatience
mais nous en a un rôle fondamental à
jouer
la dynamique on peut le constater elle
est installée
il reste huit jours de campagne il faut
donc tout donner
le 26 mai doit être un jour de victoire
pour nous
pour la france et pour l'europe yves
yves tu as commencé à les citer on va
les faire monter sur scène je vous
demande d'accueillir nos colistiers
sylvie trautmann hortense chartier
patrick brisset didier irigoin davies
l'abysse et romain beney
[Applaudissements]
ils nous viennent
beuzit ronde de la vienne et pyrénées
atlantiques de charente et de
charente-maritime
alors vous êtes si ce soir nous
entendrons ensuite guillaume guérin vous
allez évidemment chacun à faire très
court mais présentez vous et dites nous
pourquoi vous avez décidé de s'engager
dans cette belle bataille des
européennes je passe la parole à sylvie
trautmann
merci beaucoup bonsoir à tous je suis à
la fois ravis et très ému devant cette
grande salle pleine
ravi de vous retrouver tous les
républicains
cpnt et les centristes entre les deux
formations qui s'opposent que tout
oppose le rassemblement national et la
république en marche
nous devons occuper l'ensemble de
l'espace politique
personne ne doit manquer à l'appel
alors la politique dans son sens gestion
de la cité j'y suis tombé je dis
toujours quand j'étais petit j'ai un
père qui était maire pendant trente ans
d'une commune rurale dans les landes
donc mes amis sont là bonsoir centriste
élu avec la droite républicaine depuis
2001 dans la ville de pessac
soixante deux mille habitants merci il
ya quelques pessac et dans la salle
merci une ville qui a été trop longtemps
tenue par les socialistes et que nous
avons reprises en 2014 et je suis donc
aujourd'hui adjointe à l'économie à
l'emploi à la formation et présidente
d'une mission locale la mission locale
des graves
le mandat de conseillère régionale
d'aquitaine de 2010 2015 je l'exerçais
dans le groupe à l'époque ump cpnt
nouveau centre les mêmes et c'est pour
moi une expérience de collaboration
réussie entre nos formations non
seulement évidemment pour une élection
mais dans la durée
c'est pourquoi j'apprécie beaucoup de
renouer cette collaboration à l'occasion
des élections européennes
alors entre les centristes et les
républicains la décision de s'allier a
pris un peu de temps le temps nécessaire
pour reparler de nos idées pour comparer
nos idéaux mêmes nos valeurs notre
histoire commune qui s'est écrite tout
au long de la vème république
alors avec hervé morin eh bien nous
avons écouté très attentivement la
rhétorique de ce nouveau venu dans le
paysage politique médiatique aussi nous
avons découvert un homme neuf au
discours inattendu rafraîchissant
intellectuellement enrichissant nous
avons entendu françois xavier bellamy
est accepté avec enthousiasme de
partager l'aventuré avec lui avec vous
nos partenaires depuis un demi siècle
merci beaucoup sylvie patrick notre
producteur de cognac à toi producteurs
de cognac effectivement ça m'est venu
sur le tard ya 40 ans mais ma famille
était originaire de ce bassin de
production à cheval entre cognac et
saint gély qui là où sont mes racines et
c'est important de savoir où sont ses
racines une vie professionnelle après
des études qui m'ont conduit à sillonner
la france sillonné l'europe quelques
voyages à travers le monde qui m'ont
appris toute l'importance que pouvait
prendre l'europe et ce qu'elle peut nous
apporter j'ai travaillé en est qu avec l
là le désir profond et un industriel que
cette monnaie se concrétiser et
l'arrivée de l'euro a été bien sûr à
poser quelques soucis il a été une
bénédiction pour les l'activité en
général et cette fluidité qui s'est
faite au niveau du tissu des entreprises
au niveau européen
et puis c'est arrivé à cognac
pour reprendre une exploitation viticole
audio du cognac et à ce titre participé
au comité permanent du bureau national
interprofessionnel et là aussi j'ai
rencontré l'europe puisque ans et on
s'est battu pour avoir pour défendre
appellation pour défendre nos droits
pour défendre nos activités et grâce à
nos parlementaires
nous avons pu aller à bruxelles faire un
comité permanent exceptionnel et
présenter ce qui était notre spécificité
aux parlementaires qu'ils ne
comprenaient pas toujours ce qu'était le
cognac entre autres bien ce qui me fait
dire qu'il est déterminant déterminant
que nous ayons des parlementaires qui
nous représente et qui sache le faire
qu'ils aient confiance dans les
institutions qu'ils aient confiance dans
leur mission et qu'ils les remplissent
avec intelligence et continuité c'est
déterminant et puis une autre une autre
rencontre avec l'europe a été à travers
asmus erasmus c'est un projet
extraordinaire et en 2013 j'ai eu la
chance et l'honneur et l'avantagé de
participer à la création d'un groupe qui
cherchait quoi faire pour développer un
asthme us et en est sortie avec erasmus
des apprentis qui a obtenu le prix de
l'innovation politique fin 2017 et qui
développe plus de 400 millions d'euros
actuellement c'est un projet
extraordinaire et dernier point et
dernier point parce que c'est ça me
conduit tout naturellement vers ce
qu'est la culture
nous avons dans notre programme un point
fantastique qui est le 1 % culture c'est
quelque chose qui nous différencie de
tous et on le démontre à travers cette
campagne
quand on met de l'intelligence on est au
dessus des autres on est meilleur parce
qu'on est plus compréhensible plus
visible cette intelligence c'est celle
qui nous motive c'est celle qui nous
fait aller de l'avant et je suis très
très fier de participer en tant que
centriste
à cette liste il était évident qu'on en
serait et je suis très heureux d'en être
merci beaucoup patrick hein
hortense alors élu local ici en gironde
la locale de l'étape comme l'a rappelé
yves je ne me voyais pas en fait laissé
la place à la république en marche au
front national
donc étant élu d'opposition c'était
évidemment quand françois xavier m'a
proposé de rejoindre sa liste
c'était une évidence de donner une
troisième voie pour l'europe et donc
pour porter ce projet européen aux côtés
de l'ensemble des colistiers et avec
guillaume guérin sur la région nouvelle
aquitaine
merci hortense houssen presse de retard
voire pouvait applaudir didier rigual
nous vient des pyrénées atlantiques
bonsoir à tous bon sens bordeaux
permettez moi de faire un petit clin
d'oeil à tous mes amis basques et
béarnais qui sont dans la salle et ils
sont nombreux
je vais très bref parce que vous n'êtes
pas forcément venu nous écouter à nous
simplement ma fierté de faire partie de
cette liste avec toi françois xavier une
très grande fierté en tant que maire
d'une commune rurale la commune de
biganos
alors je sais que tout le monde connaît
donc je vais pas m'étaler dessus et si
pour les gens qui ne la connaissent pas
vous pouvez venir la visiter pas tous
ensemble parce que je pourrai pas vous
accueillir tous ensemble une commune
rurale de 270 habitants
je suis fier de représenter la ruralité
dans cette liste en tant que maire d'une
commune rurale mais j'ai envie de dire
mais rossi représentant cette belle
france ô 36000 communes
cette belle france des territoires
oubliés par le président macro et que
nous on met en valeur donc rien que pour
ça je suis très heureux de faire partie
de cette liste et je vous passe le
message suivant mes amis ce soir il nous
reste huit jours pour convaincre une
voix comptent double on fait du boulot
sur le terrain mais sans vous on est
rien je vous demande qu'une chose pour
françois xavier pour laurent parce que
si laurent n'était pas là n'oubliez pas
une chose on serait jamais là ce soir et
je veux qu'on lui fasse dessus d'une
ovation
[Applaudissements]
donc pour françois savy bellamy et les
soixante dix neuf colistiers pour
laurent notre président je vous demande
une chose le 26 mai nous devons
absolument écrire la première page de la
reconstruction de notre droit
merci à tous travaux didier bravo alors
david c'est un ami
c'est un militant parmi les militants il
nous vient de châtelaillon en charente
maritime vous pouvez appeler dire d'avis
de labiche
bonsoir girondins geoffroy tu as tout
dit je suis effectivement de
châtelaillon la plus belle station
balnéaire de toute la côte atlantique
tu vas te faire des amis ce soir au
petit clin d'oeil à foulon je suis donc
secrétaire départemental de charente
maritime
toute l'équipe est présente ici avec les
petites galères qu'on a eue sur l'écart
mais ils ont tenu à être présents donc
merci à vous d'avoir fait l'effort
d'avoir pris des voitures merci à nos
parlementaires daniel laurent sénateur
de la charente maritime est le seul
député de toute la côte atlantique
didier quentin est présent ce soir et
qui nous soutient toujours faut les
saluer parce que d'abord ils ont
toujours été présents avec nous mais on
sait que les élus c'est compliqué depuis
quelques mois mais depuis un mois grâce
à laurent wauquiez qui a su faire
émerger des gens un peu comme moi par
rapport au terrain et qu'à trouver
forcément françois-xavier bellamy et ça
a donné du peps lorsqu'il est venu chez
jean hubert lelièvre charlotte marin
charente à cognac
et là on a pu on a réussi à faire un
tour de force parce que ça avait été un
moment exceptionnel comme on aime les
faire
donc je vais lancer un défi à la gironde
puisque le 16 de la charente et de 17 de
la charente-maritime ça fait 33 donc
fait aussi bien que nous essayez de
faire élire françois-xavier bellamy le
26 mai merci david
enfin le jeune et talentueux nous étions
ensemble il ya quelques jours près de
poitiers nouveau président de la
fédération les républicains de la vienne
romain bonnet merci à tous merci
geoffroy merci à à la gironde nous
accueillir à ce soir c'est un honneur
comme je les ai rappelé à plusieurs
reprises
également il ya dix jours quand tu es
venu geoffroy d'être sur cette liste
parce que on avait tout à refaire on
nous annonce est mort c'est droite était
pour tous les commentateurs les
journalistes nous annoncer à 1 8%
et aujourd'hui quand on voit ces
dynamiques ces dynamiques grâce à
laurent wauquiez c'est dynamique grâce à
françois xavier benami ces dynamiques
façade grâce à agnès evren cette
dynamique grâce
arnaud danjean ce trio ce trio qui
rassemble notre famille politique c'est
ce trio de la droite du centre des
chasseurs c'est un eddie puyjalon
présent chasse pêche nature et
traditions à nos côtés aujourd'hui
merci je sais que c'est un territoire
qui tient à coeur en tout cas merci
vraiment beaucoup d'être à nos côtés
aujourd'hui cette liste c'est une liste
d'expérience de renouvellement avec des
personnalités de différents horizons moi
même moi même je représente un peu ce
monde ouvrier j'suis chaudronnier
soudeur en ligne et vous voyez
aujourd'hui cette diversité dans notre
famille politique elle existe elle
existe aussi sociétalement et c'est très
important de la réforme est aujourd'hui
chers amis il nous reste comme on l'a
dit mais qu'au lycée le long dix neuf
jours neuf jours pour aller convaincre
neuf jours pour aller chercher quelques
voix quelques voix qui nous permettrons
j'en suis convaincue de dépasser la
république en marche je crois qu'on peut
y arriver
c'est vous c'est vous qui est la clé du
scrutin c'est vous comme à la vienne
comme dans les deux sèvres je parle au
nom du poitou puisque je suis à la fois
le candidat dans la vienne et il n'y a
pas de temps dire de seine ont été ce
matin at war on était présent on était
présents étaient nombreux à thouars avec
lui les pouilles est d'ailleurs chers
amis chers un sénateur qui nous fait
l'honneur d'être un d'être ici et on a
fait moi j'ai eu des retours sur le
terrain on avait un ministre de la
république en marche qui était présent
il est venu échanger les très très
rapidement reparti parce qu'il est dans
mes ceir partie parce que ça se passait
pas très bien pour lui
très clairement non mais il faut le dire
et il dit comment vous faites vous les
républicains et vous avez plus de
travail oui parce que nous on est là
régulièrement on est sur le terrain à la
différence de vous donc merci chère dame
il ya toute mon équipe qui tient
vraiment alors alors faire une dédicace
ce soir qui étaient présents dans la
salle
et sans eux sans eux je tiens à le dire
mais c'est partout dans tous les autres
départements sans les militants de
terrain on ne serait rien et donc un
grand merci à mon équipe dans la vienne
comme un grand merci à toutes à tout
l'annuel aquitaine qui a aujourd'hui et
prénom merci merci à tous
ils sont dynamiques ça sert engagez vous
pouvez vraiment les ovationner merci de
ce que vous faites vous incarnez à
droite
merci à eux
alors maintenant je vous invite à
découvrir le clip de campagne pour
refonder l'europe et pour rétablir la
france
[Applaudissements]
chers amis nous vivons une période de
crise avec le sentiment inquiétant de ne
plus pouvoir agir
nous perdons du terrain dans la
compétition économique et technologique
notre défense et nos forces de sécurité
sont durement éprouvés par la menace
terroriste
[Musique]
une immigration non maîtrisée
déstabilise notre société
dans cette crise déconstruire le projet
européen serait une folie mais il serait
tout aussi absurde le poursuivre dans la
voie d'une europe qui ne marche pas
notre projet c'est de construire
l'europe qui pourra nous renforcer pour
ne plus subir notre avenir
l'europe nous voulons c'est celle qui
les font enfin nos entreprises et nos
emplois en assumant une préférence
européenne et nationale qui protège
notre environnement par une barrière
écologique
pour imposer les mêmes règles à ce qu'
un courte chez nous car nos propres
producteurs et à nos agriculteurs
qui met fin pause élargissement et qui
défend nos frontières face au défi
migratoire l'europe que nous voulons
c'est celle qui respecte les citoyens
qui renonce à l'excès de normes et de
contrôle pour nos artisans nos
commerçants nos entreprises
celles qui roulent ou au contraire avec
les grands projets sur l'industrie la
défense les transports ou la santé
celle qui fédère ram le laboratoire de
recherche pour guérir la maladie
d'alzheimer
l'europe nous voulons c'est celle qui
redécouvre de calais d'abord une
civilisation un élan magnifique
l'histoire de nos racines qu'il faut
nommer les transmettre
pierrot éviter le communautarisme qui
fracturent nos sociétés il faut assumer
ce lien qui nous unit
nous voulons arrêter de céder du terrain
à l'islamisme l'europe doit définir une
charte des devoirs qu'il faudra
respecter boursiers d'abus
quand on vous demande quelle europe
voulez vous répondez nous voulons
l'europe de la civilisation et
l'identité
c'est cette europe pour laquelle nous
nous engageons
nous sommes les seuls à défendre ce
projet solide clair et cohérent dans
quelques jours vous aurez dans vos mains
un choix décisif pour refonder l'europe
et pour rétablir la france
[Musique]
sa présence ce soir est très importante
pour nous il dirige un mouvement qui
existe depuis 30 ans et qui porte les
valeurs de la ruralité des traditions
auxquelles nous sommes tant attachés
vous pouvez accueillir eddie puyjalon le
président de chasse pêche nature et
tradition
[Musique]
or m'excuserez la campagne est un peu
longue
les nuits sont très courtes j'ai dû
piocher un peu trop les trois heures de
sommeil par nuit j'ai donc attrapé la
crème de ce matin après la réunion
d'hier sur canal à bordeaux donc la voie
tiens encore un peu mais la motivation
est là
comptez sur moi pour continuer à nous
battre jusqu'au 26 mai alors je voulais
juste un premier remercier les cadres de
cpnt c'est vrai que j'oublie parfois on
est tellement dévoué pour nos amis les
républicains que j'en oublie de
remercier ma famille politique parfois
et le fait qu' ils ont quand même choisi
la voie pour lequel je vais entraîner
parfois dans les tous foire parfois dans
l'effacement où on nous dit toujours
vous n'existez pas vous n'êtes plus là
vous n'êtes pas politique mais non
peut-être que quelque part par là car
les gens ont fait l'effort d'être des
gens loyaux sincère et qui voulait aider
quand le moment était le plus difficile
est depuis 2007
on y est passée par là on a sauvé
quelques parlementaires parce que c'est
important d'avoir encore un groupe
lr puissant à l'assemblée nationale au
sénat on a fait le don de nous mais
aujourd'hui je suis fier d'être là parce
qu'on reprend du poids et peut-être
qu'on est un peu pour quelque chose
alors merci à mes cadres alors on se
connaît bien
ça fait depuis 2007 quand les meetings
les campagnes et donc ici on est une
grande famille je reconnais des visages
beaucoup de visages d'abord les visages
de la fidélité
les visages de la valeur vous savez j'y
suis très attaché donc vous tous qui
êtes là ce soir
je voulais que vous à policier parce que
vraiment une belle famille et la belle
famille de la droite elle est là ce soir
alors je suis un girondin et puis
j'accueille donc la politesse c'est
quand même d'inciter tous ceux qui sont
là à combat c'est parce qu'ils
travaillent beaucoup pour les
républicains
je commençais pour les gens de sens
commun parce que je partage avec marion
julie que la tournerie conseil régional
on brasse tous les deux et puis il ya
aussi jean louis grotte planche alors
vous allez entendre parler de militaires
j'y peux rien j'aime les gens qui sont
engagés avec une volonté avec un courage
mais une colonne et l'engagement de jean
louis me fait plaisir
il ya aussi les gens se diraient des
compagnons du mil les gens qui sont là
qui organise tout qui étaient là dans
les salles les fidèles parmi les fidèles
toujours présente pour distribuer les
tracts et les affiches assurer les
meetings claude durieux malgré les
difficultés il est là je te salue tu es
un ami et on peut compter sur toi et
c'est important mais je voudrais
remercier les centristes r&d -
doublement d'abord pour la présence ici
sur cette liste les centristes c'est
important et deuxièmement parce
qu'arriver à jouer le jeu et aux
régionales il a mis un de nos policiers
sur cette liste de la normandie qui est
aujourd'hui 31e sur la liste grâce à
laurent et à vous tous mais qui fait un
super boulot à la région et pour lequel
garde et lui a donné la place qu'il
mérite et celui de s'occuper des zones
humides sur les scpi de la chasse et
dieu sait que pour cpnt s'occuper de la
chasse c'est une vocation
voilà donc merci aux centristes un merci
particulier alors quelques candidats je
citerai pas tous mais je ne pouvais pas
faire moins quand même pour ceux de la
région
merci à david labiche charente-maritime
lui aussi sur la liste mais pour tous
que plusieurs raisons on travaille tous
les deux sur le terrain on partage
plusieurs valeurs la peinture le dessin
la gastronomie ça me va bien mon cher
david on va continuer lundi on sera en
charente maritime sur les bourrelets
suaire parce que là aussi il faut avoir
un peu de caractère et on est là nous à
droite pour défendre la vie des gens et
on va aller voir ce qui s'y passe
pourquoi on veut leur imposer des
éoliennes à leur place dans beau marais
merci david
un grand merci à à hortense
alors forcément hortense et la gironde
et puis en plus c'est le boss avait nous
à la région elle fait un super boulot
des filles engagées j'adore ça quand
elles sont jeunes quinzaine colonne
vertébrale j'adore encore plus dans
merci merci à tort tant scipion va
continuer ce boulot parce qu'on a bien
entamé sa alors après j'ai bien passé à
toi la figure de rugbyman chasseurs on
va faire tout pour qu'on gagne et
t'inquiète pas on va se revoir pour les
faire une partie de chasse et 1er mai
paris la 17e position c'est la belle
gueule comme vous dis moi je l'appelle
le talentueux il est notre président de
groupe à la région de l'aquitaine
c'est avec lui qu'on s'exercer la fine
lame contre rousset et dieu sait que ça
me va bien et dieu sait que je l'aimé
bien
je nomme guillaume guérin c'est un type
bien alors pour guillaume vous savez pas
tout parce qu'on a quand même quelque
chose de particulier avec guillaume
c'est que si moi je suis président de
cpnt lui le président des républicains
du limousin
mais pas seulement c'est que si moi je
suis à la fois en quarts tcp noté j'ai
aussi ma carte membre fondateur des
républicains est un ami guillaume guérin
est aussi adhérente de cp à noter donc
j'ai une petit chasseur qui est en place
sur cette liste
et si on travaille bien je dis bien si
on travaillait bien si les comètes
s'alignent bien si françoise aviez nous
fait une remontée d'adam faire il sera
élu et j'aurai une part de cpnt au
parlement européen
c'est tout ce que je souhaite
aujourd'hui
merci guillaume pour ceux de la valeur
comme partage
merci à tous les élus vous êtes très
nombreux je vais pas tout vous saluer
mais je sais que vous êtes tous en train
de faire le boulot et puis que vous
prenez plaisir aujourd'hui à 7 cette
tendance la banane colonna ça fait
longtemps qu'on l'attendait ouais on a
accompagné mais aujourd'hui on prend du
plaisir parce qu'on était la durée et
aujourd'hui ça se concrétise
j'ai quand même un message d'amitié
personnelle j'avais un adresser c'est
celui pour mon ami hugues martin encore
un militaire certes mais parce que j'ai
une profonde estime pour lui le sait
parce qu'il a été toujours il a une
ténacité il a une fidélité à notre
famille politique que j'aimerais que
vous la police est très fort merci
dumartin pour cette colonne vertébrale
que tu as et tu nous fait plaisir
alors maintenant mon merci c'est pour
toi laurent d'abord parce que tu as
continuer ce travail de partenariat avec
nous et que tu le sais on se voit
souvent si la fidélité la fidélité la
fidélité mais il ya des liens qui se
sont tissés et je te remercie de sa déjà
et puis le fait d'avoir reconstruit la
droite puisque nous on attendait on
était là derrière on pouvait pas agir
plus que nous pourrions mais en internat
à côté de toi on n'attendait qu'une
chose c'est que effectivement tu leur
construise cette famille et tu l'as fait
peur merveilleusement en plus de ça tu
le fait d'une manière que beaucoup de
militants ici attendent c'est à dire que
la droite est la plus à se taire elle a
plus à recevoir d'ordres pour dire c'est
qu'elle est là dire aujourd'hui libéré
la parole qui le fait très bien et tu le
fait avec talent sur des sujets qui sont
importants alors je vais vous dire que
ça fait du bien depuis que la maison est
solidement ancré sur ses valeurs et que
les anguilles
vous savez celles qui n'ont pas de
colonne vertébrale celles qui ont quitté
le navire pour un plat de lentilles ceux
qui ont couru au son du pipeau de la
macro ni et dieu sait que nous on a
notre part un nouvel aquitaine
que ça fait du bien d'être dans une
famille enfin unis engagée pour
l'intérêt général
engagée pour l'intérêt supérieur comme
le faisait le général de gaulle c'est
important d'avoir cette famille
aujourd'hui unis et qui marche dans le
même sens tous derrière françois xavier
bellamy oui tu as raison
l'oim il faut croire en ses valeurs ne
jamais dévié et à danser pour conquérir
le coeur des français sur le fondement
de ce que nous voulons pour la france et
pour l'europe de demain
jamais le nouveau monde promis par macro
ne sera la réponse est l'avenir du pays
jamais un ramassis de déserteurs fera
une une arme et courageuse pour défendre
la patrie
jamais la droite ne sera la gauche
emmanuel macron s'y tromper il s'est
trompé
certes il a réussi à démolir les
socialistes mais avec la droite
ils ont mis une chose c'est que nous
nous avons de l'honneur et que nous nous
baserons jamais nos valeurs qui nous
animent aujourd'hui comme demain et
comme demain pour faire gagner
françois-xavier bel habit alors oui vous
pouvez applaudir laurent pour le travail
qu'il a fait pour notre famille
politique mais tu as un autre mérite
laurent c'est d'avoir à se chercher la
petite pépite la petite pépite est la
lumière qui est arrivé mais je vais
faire redondant mais on a tous c'est
pareil
la première fois que j'ai entendu
françois xavier bellamy je n'ai eu que
des superlatifs brillant intelligent
rafraîchissant dit stop il va avoir les
chevilles qui gonflent pas du tout je
vais quand même c'est le contraire 35
j'avais n'est pas de cette nature là il
a une qualité qui me fait encore plus
l'apprécier et vous savez je suis pas un
homme à passer la brosse à reluire
facilement mais françois qui avait au
delà d'être instruit intelligent il a
cette petite dose de politesse de bonne
éducation de pudeur d'empathie de
simplicité qui pour moi le rural est une
chose extrêmement importante
alors
merci françois xavier bellamy pour cette
belle campagne pourtant un engagement
que ça fait du bien d'avoir
françois-xavier bellamy et à droite que
ça pue du bien de la voir aller nous et
ça et ça j'adore cher françois xavier
merci à toi pour cette belle campagne
pour l'intelligence avec laquelle tu
fait la liaison entre la ville et la
campagne
il ya une quinzaine d'années j'étais
tête de liste aux européennes au cirque
d'hiver à paris
je disais un peuple un peuple qui perce
et récupère ses racines est un peuple
qui se meurt et je ne voulais pas mourir
alors aujourd'hui merci à toi françois
xavier de défendre nos racines
françaises européennes chrétienne rural
pour moi et pour tous les français comme
vous le savez et je le dis à chaque
meeting cpnt chasse pêche nature
traditions mais aussi gastronomie pour
la défense de la ruralité et de la
france qui nous est cher merci xavier de
porter haut et fort les couleurs de la
ruralité la chasse la pêche les
traditions rurales culturelles
traditionnelles notre économie le
tourisme la gastronomie l'agriculture
élevage la viticulture la sylviculture
et tellement d'autres composantes qui
sont pleinement ancré dans cette
campagne des européennes notamment par
la présence de nombreuses listes qui
abrite aujourd'hui une forte dose
d'écologie radical d' écologie punitive
celle qui encourage notamment le
véganisme ceux qui attaquent les
bouchers et charcutiers les poissonniers
les éleveurs les apiculteurs les
pêcheurs les chasseurs
ceux qui attaquent injustement tout
notre monde rural nos racines ma racine
mes racines de france à moins elles sont
aujourd'hui menacés et la france des
terroirs de la défendre avec 3
xavier b amis en europe nous en avons
bien besoin alors oui mon coeur saigne
quand on attaque le monde rural quand
l'europe impose des ours et des loups à
la place et d'héberger des brebis
quand on nous impose aujourd'hui des
forêt d'éoliennes à la place de nos plus
beaux paysages
alors oui mon coeur saigne je veux
défendre ma france celle que j'aime
celle que nous aimons tous celle de
toujours
enfin comme un étau pour les t'il
possible aujourd'hui de voter pour
l'auberge espagnole
de la république en marche là où un
agriculteur est à côté de deux
écologistes anti tout l'un qui veut du
glyphosate des autres qui ne veulent pas
le en même temps de la macro ni c'est
une vaste tromperie
le peuple de france ne veut plus être
soumis en permanence aux directives
liberticide
le peuple de france ne veux pas voir
disparaître ces églises ses traditions
son identité
le peuple de france et une europe forte
conduite par des hommes et des femmes
qui dépendront les valeurs sans
compromission mais avec conviction et je
sais françois que j'avais que tu as
plein de conviction dans ces élections
- le chasseur le gaulois fric frac terre
le girondin et bientôt le retraité
nantis alors chez monsieur macro je suis
un cumulard pour vous je préfère les
oiseaux du sud-ouest à l'oiseau de la
république en marche et
et encore moins les oiseaux de mauvais
augure du rassemblement national car
tous n'apporte aucune solution sérieuse
pour redonner à la france sa place dans
l'europe et celle de l'europe dans le
monde
alors oui oui on retrouve un vent
d'espoir une dynamique pour nous et nous
devons l'amplifier jusqu'au 26 mai pour
créer la belle surprise de ces élections
il y a toujours une surprise dans les
élections européennes et fait que avec
vous avec moi avec cpnt la surprise ça
soit françois-xavier bellamy le 26 mai
prochain
vive la république vive la france vive
rivalité
b
il a la pêche est dit il et sportif
on est très heureux de cette alliance
avec le cpnt alors ai dit tu l'as déjà
présenté il est l'un des principaux
talents de la nouvelle droite que porte
laurent wauquiez vous pouvez applaudir
guillaume guérin
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
chers amis
quel plaisir d'avoir une salle aussi
plein à bordeaux ce soir
mesdames messieurs les parlementaires
mesdames et messieurs les élus cher
président chérif foulon c'est un immense
honneur pour moi de m'exprimer dans
cette salle bordelaise ce soir en tant
que président du groupe d'opposition au
sein du conseil régional et c'est une
des premières fois où je découvre cette
droite du sud-ouest rassemblés dans un
grand meeting après celui des régionales
à limoges ou à l'époque on avait réussi
mon cher laurent l'exploit de réunir
nicolas sarkozy et alain juppé à la même
tribune
alors je suis sûr que vous êtes tous là
est ce que les basques eux sont là les
béarnais les périgourdins les girondins
les picto charentais et les limousins
vous avez intérêt d'être là je vous
remercie
je n'ai pas oublié les landais je vais
vous dire pourquoi parce que je voulais
dire la vérité
j'avais reçu ce matin un sms de votre
secrétaire départemental et dont je vous
ai elle a gardé pour la fin des jeux
vous le dire maintenant qui m'a dit
surtout n'oublie pas les landes est donc
bienvenu hollandais mais ils viennent en
voisins et j'espère qu'ils sont les plus
nombreux possibles
[Applaudissements]
alors une fois une fois de plus cher
françois xavier ont fait le plein la
salle est complète
comme partout où tu te déplaces avec
laurent et ça ce n'était pas forcément
gagné d'avancé
il y a quelques mois alors laurent vient
de me dire surtout tu t'y pas tu parle
pas de moi tu parles pas de françois
xavier
c'est pas important c'est pas grave si
si moi je vous le dit c'est très
important parce que ce qu'il se passe en
ce moment est quelque chose de nouveau
pour la première fois depuis les
élections législatives
notre famille politique se réunit se
rassemblent au cours des différents
meetings qui se déroule à l'occasion de
cette campagne européenne pour la
première fois depuis bien longtemps
nous avons réuni rassemblés dans ses
meetings des gens qui ne partageaient
pas forcément les mêmes idées qui
parfois ab des querelles d'ego et
aujourd'hui ont réussi grâce à la
candidature de françois xavier bellamy
grâce à cette magnifique campagne qui
est en train d'être menées ont réussi ce
challenge de rassembler la famille
politique
alors françois xavier puis y est pour
beaucoup tout y est pour beaucoup parce
que à titre purement personnel tu vas
profondément impressionné par sa
combativité par ton humilité par la
densité et par cette proximité naturelle
que tu tisse avec tous ceux qui te
croise je crois vraiment que tu es une
révélation futur pour notre famille
politique de droite et du centre droit
je crois sincèrement que tu est en
mesure de créer une énorme surprise le
26 mai au soir
mes chers amis françois-xavier bellamy
et le tête de liste d'une liste de 79
non avec la magnifique trio composé
d'arnaud danjean et d'agnès evren ce
trio c'est notre président des
républicains qui l'a voulu c'est laurent
wauquiez ne l'oublié pas et rien que
pour cela une ovation au toit du monde
françois-xavier tuer ce supplément d'âme
dont cette triste campagne des
européennes avaient besoin toutes listes
confondues
tu pars ton propos par la hauteur de vue
qui est la tienne tueur et intéresse des
gens à la chose publique et urée
intéresse un certain nombre de nos
concitoyens à la politique
ce rassemblement que vous êtes en train
de réussir
quel que soit j'allais dire le score que
nous ferons le 26 mai prochain il aura
un sens il aura un sens pour l'avenir
parce que si le président macron a
réussi à faire exploser la gauche en
mille morceaux a amené le parti
socialiste autour de 5%
ce n'est pas le cas de notre famille
politique nous sommes aujourd'hui dans
les sondages la troisième voie
l'outsider comme ils disent et ça ce
n'était pas forcément gagné d'avancé a
réussi par ton discours par le soutien
de laurent par le soutien de tous nos
parlementaires de tous nos grands mères
a démontré que l'on pouvait avoir un
discours de droite affirmé en
réaffirmant nos valeurs nos fondamentaux
tout en tendant la main à nos
partenaires historiques que sont les
centristes du centre droit et je tiens à
ce que voulaient saluer et les féliciter
chaleureusement
cette droite elle se reconstruit parce
qu'elle est fidèle à ses valeurs elle
remplit les salles et vous l'avez vu ça
agace un certain nombre de personnes
nous sommes caricaturé par des gens
importants de ce gouvernement
le premier d'entre eux nous serions la
droite 3 cadero eh bien je vais vous
dire quelque chose je suis fier
d'appartenir à cette droite de trocadéro
cette droite qui s'est rassemblée en
2012 autour de nicolas sarkozy et qui
s'est rassemblée dans la tempête autour
de françois fillon
cette droite du trocadéro c'est tout
simplement la droite républicaine tel
que nous l'aimons est telle que vous
l'aimez alors nous sommes rassemblés
nous sommes rassemblés et c'est bien ce
qui inquiète le gouvernement c'est pour
ça qu'on veut essayer de vous faire
croire à une élection européenne qui ne
serait ni plus ni moins que le troisième
tour de l'élection présidentielle où il
n'y aurait pas de match et où il
faudrait trancher entre les gentils
progressistes et les méchants populiste
où il faudrait donner un chèque en blanc
emmanuel macron pour qu'ils aillent bat
madame le pen et madame le pen
s'adressant à son électorat en disant
voté pour moi pour grippe bat emmanuel
macron je crois que ce débat européen
françois-xavier tu l'a démontré mérite
beaucoup mieux qu'un duel stérile entre
deux formations politiques qui n'ont
jamais rien amené de bon pour notre pays
mais qu'il n'emmènerait absolument rien
de bon au niveau européen
ce sera le premier test après les
élections législatives
le premier vrai test il aura des
conséquences nationales et des
conséquences bien sûr européenne sur les
conséquences nationales nous allons être
extrêmement scruter sur le score que
nous allons réaliser et nous serons plus
ou moins écoutés audible par tous les
observateurs de la vie politique et
particulièrement par les autres
formations politiques
donc le 26 mai prochain il y a bien sûr
l'enjeu européen je vais y venir très
rapidement et françois-xavier
s'exprimant longuement sur le sujet mais
il ya aussi un enjeu local la droite
républicaine française
les républicains associés à leurs
partenaires de centre-droit joue à
l'occasion de ces élections européennes
une part de leur histoire future donc il
est essentiel
chers amis au-delà de l'enjeu européen
de vous mobiliser pour que l'on soit à
la plus haut plus fort taux possible de
votants à l'occasion de ces élections
européennes c'est absolument essentiel
pour l'avenir notre formation politique
sur le plan européen je crois en toute
franchise que grâce aux équipes de
laurent grâce à l'ensemble de nos élus
nous avons tout simplement le programme
le plus construit on a passé un an à
rédiger notre programme on s'est arrêté
sur des thématiques qui sont chers à
notre électorat qui sont des thématiques
fédérative au niveau européen des
thématiques essentielles
je ne serai pas très long mais comment
ne pas évoquer ici en nouvelle aquitaine
qu'il a plu la régie de la plus grosse
région agricole d'europe comment ne pas
parler du projet agricole aujourd'hui le
projet agricole d'emmanuel macron parce
qu'il faut bien dire que c'est emmanuel
macron madame réseau ayant complètement
disparu de la campagne je parle du
président de la république et le
programme agricole de madame le pen il y
a une voie centrale qui est la nôtre
mais chez makro ont fait les yeux doux
aux agriculteurs à l'occasion du salon
annuel
il a abattu un record il a passé 14
heures à versailles formidable il a fait
272 selphy avec que tout ce qui se
promenait dans les couloirs chèvres
moutons à new mais la réalité est cher
ami la réalité est tout autre c'est
qu'en ce moment se renégocie le budget
de la future pac 2020 2027
la france s'apprête à être amputé de 15
% de son budget soit une perte de 7
milliards d'euros pour les exploitants
agricoles français et bien je peux vous
assurer que dans une région comme la
nôtre
cette nouvelle aquitaine
terre de polyculture-élevage vous
retrouvez aussi bien des éleveurs
allaitants dans l'eau 20 des éleveurs
allaitants dans le bovin on ne peut pas
se permettre de perdre vingt mille euros
par exploitation avec une baisse de 15%
du budget de la pac
ce n'est tout simplement pas possible et
on ne peut pas continuer à laisser
emmanuel macron déroulée dans un cynisme
absolu des grandes déclarations d'amour
aux agriculteurs et les laisser faire
tout le contraire dans les négociations
qu'il mène avec la commission européenne
sur le plan sécuritaire et là je
m'adresse aux électeurs du sud ouest et
particulièrement aux électeurs bordeaux
ne va pas se mentir il y à une porosité
dans l'électorat de droite et le
centre-droit
dans ce sud ouest et particulièrement
sur la métropole bordelaise entre notre
liste est là lille emmanuel macron à
ceux qui vous disent que notre programme
sécuritaire est trop musclé trop dur je
veux leur répondre qu'ils ont tout faux
ils ont tout faux parce que quand ils le
proposent
notre vision de l'immigration
aujourd'hui à celle des pères fondateurs
de l'europe
il faut juste leur expliquer une chose
c'est qu'entre temps les grands enjeux
ont considérablement changé
est-ce que les enjeux étaient les mêmes
pour monnaie et pour sumann lorsqu'ils
ont fondé cette union européenne que les
enjeux qui se posent à nous aujourd'hui
dirigeants occidentaux
les enjeux sont complètement différents
et les réponses qui doivent apporter à
ces enjeux doivent être beaucoup plus
radicale lorsque l'on dit avec
françois-xavier bellamy que nous
souhaitions que nous souhaitons que les
centres de traitement des droits d'asile
pour l'immigration illégale se passe sur
le continent africain
ce n'est pas d'être d'extrême droite que
de dire ça c'est tout simplement
protéger notre sol occidental protéger
notre civilisation européenne
emmanuel macron en voulant instruire ces
demandes d'asile sur le territoire
européen ouvre notre continent à une
immigration illégale de masse qui n'aura
de cesse que de s'amplifier pour les
années à venir pour une raison simple
ne serait-ce que la raison climatique et
par conséquent au regard de tous ces
éléments là il faut être beaucoup plus
ferme que nous l'étions par le passé sur
cette thématique là il y a des vraies
différences d'approché
quant au front national vous en
connaissez en milieu rural manche et
ready shota sur ta zone géographique qui
vous dise madame le pen a le meilleur
des projets sur le plan de la lutte
contre l'immigration mais vous savez
entre les discours de madame le pen et
l'effet de madame le pen il y a des
choses totalement différentes
pourquoi le groupe dans lequel siègent
madame le pen au parlement européen
n'at-il pas voter les crédits
supplémentaires à l' agence frontex
pourquoi madame le pen at-elle refusé de
voter le pnr c'est à dire
l'identification des passagers dans les
avions posé la question aux militants du
front national il y a les grands
discours et il y à la réalité des faits
et c'est pas tout à fait la même chose
[Applaudissements]
alors on essaye de vous dire et je vais
conclure avant que geoffroy me dise
d'arrêter on vous dit le 26 mai il faut
voter utile mais mes amis ne vous
trompez pas de combat
c'est une élection à la proportionnelle
c'est une élection qui vise non pas à
désigner un président de la république
mais une élection qui vise à désigner
des futurs représentants au sein du
parlement européen et à ceux qui vous
disent le vote utile c'est le vote
macron je leur répond absolument pas le
vote utile c'est le vote en faveur de la
liste conduite par françois xavier
bellamy pour une raison très simple on
ne rejoue pas le deuxième tour de
l'élection présidentielle on joue une
élection européenne pour envoyer des
députés européens dans un groupe
politique qui existe déjà et qui sera
majoritaire qui s'appelle le ppe
à cinquante monsieur macro on vous dit
on va changer l'europe
on va mettre l'europe en marche monsieur
macron se plante
parce que monsieur matte ronde demain
matin est incapable d'avoir un groupe
politique majoritaire et je m'adresse à
l'électorat rural dans quel groupe
les élus de monsieur macron vont ils
siégeaient dans quel groupe monsieur
qu'enfin fondateur du sigle wwf va-t-il
siéger monsieur qu'enfin vous savez ce
fait partie de cette race de politique
que j'adore je les appelle les pastèques
ils sont verts à l'extérieur extrêmement
rouge à l'intérieur monsieur qu enfin
monsieur quentin bat il siéger avec la
ld eu le groupe des libéraux financé par
une grande entreprise qui s'appelle
bayer monsanto et vous expliquer droit
dans les yeux qu'il est contre le
glyphosate mes amis est ce que ce
nouveau monde est sérieux
sincèrement est-ce que ce nouveau monde
est sérieux
lorsque l'on voit la constitution de la
liste durant canfin et que l'on voit les
soutiens qui est en train d'engranger
cette liste actuellement
est ce que ce nouveau monde est sérieux
quel est le point commun entre des gens
qui dans leur région ont combattu
activement ségolène royal pendant 20 ans
qui aujourd'hui se retrouvent à
batailler au côté de cette même ségolène
royal et de madame guigou pour sauver le
soldat l'oiseau est ce que ce nouveau
monde est sérieux le 26 mai il n'y a
qu'un seul choix qu'un vote utile c'est
celui de françois xavier bellamy un
siège ses 130 140 ou 150 mille voix en
fonction du nombre de voix perdues par
les listes qui auront fait moins de 5%
vous êtes une heymans famille politique
grâce à laurent nous remplissons les
salles partout où nous passons
aujourd'hui je suis convaincu que vous
êtes convaincu alors demain soyez
convaincant et le 26 mai faites voter en
masse pour la liste de françois xavier
et nous réussirons l'énorme surprise de
ces élections européennes
je vous remercie
bravo aux veaux guillaume il a dit
beaucoup de vérités qui dérangent et
mobilisez vous pour le faire élire au
parlement européen le 26 mai prochain
dans quelques minutes nous entendrons le
président de notre famille politique
dont tu as parlé
laurent mais en attendant il est celui
que vous attendez tous
ils portent notre liste avec talon
énergie et humilité vous pouvez
ovationné françois-xavier bellamy
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
chers amis merci infiniment et merci
d'abord à vous tous d'être présent ce
soir merci d'être si nombreux
j'arrive comme laurent de paris j'étais
encore à midi sur les plateaux de
télévision
et bien je peux vous dire une chose
c'est que sur les plateaux de télévision
à paris il ya une seule certitude ce que
vous n'existez pas cette élection elle
est plié elle est finie rentrez chez
vous qu'est ce que vous faites là de
toute façon le débat il est déjà
installé et on ne cesse de nous demander
par tous de nous placer dans un camp
comme si tout était déjà joué comme si
c'était tu l'as dit guillaume le
troisième tour de l'élection
présidentielle une sorte d'éternel
retour cauchemardesque vers ce débat
d'entre deux tour entre marine le pen et
emmanuel macron et bien moi je dis que
rien n'est joué d'avancé et la meilleure
preuve de cela c'est votre présence ce
soir ici à bordeaux merci l'appli fille
ce soir
je voudrais remercier de tout coeur tous
les élus qui sont ici remercier nos
parlementaires nos sénateurs qui sont là
nombreux remercier didier quentin le
député qui a survécu à la tempête de
2017 remercier tous nos mères qui
représente ce par quoi à la france tient
encore debout nos conseillers municipaux
conseillers départementaux aux
conseillers régionaux dans un moment de
crise profonde je le vois depuis le
début de cette campagne partout en
france ils sont ce par quoi notre
démocratie résiste à la défiance qui ne
cesse de monter
tous ces élus de terrain qui dans la
discrétion et le silence retisse le
tissu social abîmé réparé ce qui est
déchiré rapproche ce qui s'est éloigné
et je crois que nous devons leur dire ce
soir notre reconnaissance pour tout le
travail qu'ils font ils sont la force de
notre famille politique et sont la force
de la france
[Applaudissements]
je voudrais remercier aussi tous ceux
qui portent avec nous cette campagne
remercier en particulier bien sûr nos
amis centristes hervé morin et puis
remercié puisque ce soir c'est chez toi
que nous sommes je voudrais dire de tout
coeur un immense merci à eddie puyjalon
tu l'as dit nous défendons ensemble
cette france que nous aimons nous
défendons cette france qui n'a pas
renoncé à elle-même qui n'a pas renoncé
à ses coutumes qui n'a pas renoncé à ce
bon mot de tradition qui fait le dernier
mot de cpnt la tradition qui vient du
latin trader et qui veut dire simplement
ce qui se transmet la france n'est pas
née d'aujourd'hui la france n'est pas un
nouveau monde
la france sait faire des start up mais
la france n'est pas une start up nation
et ce qui fait notre inventivité c'est
que nous n'avons pas commencé avec ce
monde qui se dessine
nous puisons notre génie dans cette
histoire qui remonte il y a bien loin de
ceux là dans cette histoire qui fait
cette filiation que tu évoquais à
l'instant et oui nous nous honorons oui
c'est notre fierté
et oui c'est notre honneur de pouvoir
entretenir la flamme la tradition disait
christophe malheur ça n'est pas vénérer
décembre mais c'est ce passé le feu
voilà ce que nous faisons ensemble merci
clé réduit et puis je voudrais bien sûr
remercié je les fait de nombreuses fois
mais il faut le faire encore avec vous
ce soir je voudrais remercier celui par
qui nous sommes là ensemble réunit
remercier celui qui a fait ce choix
totalement improbable qui me vaut d'être
devant vous celui qui m'a fait confiance
et j'espère que je serai à la hauteur de
son pari à la hauteur de sa confiance je
voudrais remercier laurent
laurent tu m'as fait un un double cadeau
d'abord parce que c'est un honneur
immense que d'être devant vous je sais
que je ne mérite pas les mots que vous
avez prononcé chez rives toi qui nous
accueille
tu as confiance me touche profondément
et je sais que je ne vais pas encore
méritait et qu'il va falloir maintenant
dans les semaines qui viendront dans les
années qui viendront que je puisse faire
en sorte que cette confiance soient
fondés sur ce que nous pouvons faire
ensemble pour ce territoire pour cette
ville pour cette région pour cette
fédération que tu présides pour toute
notre france que nous voulons servir
ensemble mais au fond cette confiance
que tu m'as fait laurent ça n'était pas
le seul cadeau le grand cadeau que tu
m'as fait c'est de me permettre de
partir entouré d'une équipe aussi
extraordinaire avec agnès avec arnaud
avec tous nos policiers et vous les avez
vu ce soir ils sont nombreux comme
jamais dans cette région ici ce soir et
je voudrais leur dire de tout coeur un
immense merci merci romain toi qui a été
presque de tous les meetings
merci didier tout avec qui nous avons
échangé avant même que tu sois sur cette
liste nous viendrons bien sûr dans sa
commune tous ensemble d'accords on se
donne rendez vous ensemble
merci chers hortense toi qui est aussi
une figure de notre génération sur cette
liste merci
sylvie merci patrick nous nous sommes
croisés ensemble déjà dans d'autres
rencontres
et puis merci david au fond c'est une
chance d'arriver à cette fin de campagne
déjà à la fin de campagne que de chemin
parcouru
déjà à la fin de campagne et je vois une
grande différence avec les premières
réunions c'est que maintenant quand je
rentre dans une salle je croise tant de
visages amis chers david nous avons été
chez toi en charente en charente
maritime avec d'autres qui sont ici et
nous avons partagé déjà ce qui fait la
saveur singulière de cette région où
nous sommes et puis merci bien sûr
guillaume toi qui viens de parler
guillaume toi que quand j'ai rencontré
on m'a présenté comme le plus efficace
de tous les tombes
de notre parti politique le tombeur de
limoges toi qui porte les victoire
improbable toi qui fais les succès dans
le plus grand des défis
c'est une chance incroyable que vous
soyez la force de cette liste
aujourd'hui alors au risque de te
décevoir
guillaume je ne vais pas faire la
surprise non parce que de fait je ne
peux pas faire la surprise
nous allons faire la surprise et nous
allons la faire ensemble
et nous devons la faire ensemble cette
surprise nous devons la faire ensemble
parce que c'est notre europe qui a
besoin de cette surprise c'est notre
france qui a besoin de cette surprise si
nous voulons refonder l'europe pour
pouvoir rétablir la france alors oui
nous n'avons pas le droit de manquer la
semaine qui commence car tout se joue
dans cette semaine nous sommes ici avec
le bonheur de nous retrouver ensemble
mais nous sommes aussi ici avec au coeur
une forme de gravité peut être une
inquiétude partagée
nous sommes au coeur d'une période
marquée par une crise profonde sert
hortense nous faisons partie d'une
génération avec tous les jeunes qui sont
ici ils sont nombreux ce soir d'ailleurs
et c'est une joie particulière
nous faisons partie d'une génération qui
a amené qui a découvert le monde qui a
vu naître sa conscience du monde dans
lequel nous sommes
avec ce mot de crise est partout
aujourd'hui partout où notre regard se
pose nous voyons de la crise crise
économique qui dure depuis si longtemps
crise sociale bien sûr née de cette
crise économique chômage de masse qui
traverse notre pays d'une manière
maintenant structurelles crise avec
cette défiance qui monte des
institutions crise de l'autorité crise
de l'état crise de l'état qui stats
devrait demeurer toujours et qui n'est
plus fait que de ses dettes qui semble
devoir se passer aux générations qui
viennent crise culturelle crise
éducative crise de la transmission
mais à travers même la crise de la
culture et au delà d'elle crise de la
nature crise écologique qui fait que
nous avons le sentiment que même notre
environnement semble menacée par cette
instabilité fondamentale
nous vivons une période de crise globale
et ce constat n'a pas pour but de nous
rendre inutilement des primes et non la
crise n'est pas forcément une
catastrophe
notre pays a connu des moments bien plus
tragique que celui que nous vivons
aujourd'hui
mais notre pays a sans doute rarement
connu des moments aussi critique
c'est à dire des moments où krisis comme
le dit le mot grec qui a fait à travers
cette langue notre vocabulaire
d'aujourd'hui krisis
le moment de la décision krisis en grec
veut dire le choix
nous sommes à l'heure des choix nous
sommes au moment où il faut chercher ce
nouveau cap dont nous avons besoin
prendre les décisions nécessaires pour
pouvoir faire en sorte de redessiner un
avenir de re découvrir qu'il y a
effectivement un espoir est que nous ne
sommes pas condamnés à cette fatalité
qui veut que nous soyons aujourd'hui en
train de subir un monde qui avance sans
nous au lieu de contribuer à agir pour
en infléchir la direction oui nous
sommes à l'heure des grandes décisions
et dans cette heure des grandes
décisions
il nous faut pouvoir nous appuyer sur
une europe refonder pour pouvoir être
efficace face à tous ces grands défis
face aux défis économiques et
commerciales aujourd'hui nous avons le
sentiment c'est vrai que les grandes
puissances du monde sont en dehors de
l'europe que l'avenir technologique que
l'avenir économique industrielle que
l'avenir agricole peut-être est en train
de se jouer ailleurs aux états unis en
chine en inde en amérique du sud
et pourtant nous n'avons aucune raison
de nous résigner mais il est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui nous avons le sentiment
de céder à une forme d'impuissance de
reculer de perdre du terrain de perdre
des marchés
pourquoi sinon parce que notre europe a
cédé à cette naïveté nous avons vécu
longtemps et longtemps nous avons
construit cette europe dans le rêve de
la fin de l'histoire
la fin de l'histoire si vous vous en
souvenez ce concept inventé par un
philosophe américain qui s'appelait
francis fukuyama dans les années 90
francis fukuyama avait écrit ce livre la
fin de l'histoire dans lequel il pose
est le constat suivant le mur de berlin
s'est effondré et personne ne s'est
enfui à l'est
certains ont mis du temps à s'en rendre
compte le mur de berlin s'est effondré
et personne ne s'est enfui à l'est et
donc l'histoire a tranché l'empiré
soviétique s'est écroulé et personne ne
le regrette et donc c'est le triomphe
d'un seul modèle le modèle de la
démocratie libérale le modèle de
l'économie de marché et avec le triomphe
de ce modèle destiné à devenir universel
le monde va désormais vivre la fin de
l'histoire humaine la fin de toutes les
péripéties qui ont fait l'histoire
humaine
oh bien sûr disait fukuyama il y aura
encore des gazettes dans laquelle on
racontera les résultats des matchs de
foot mais il y aura plus de grands
événements plus de guerre plus de
conflits désormais toutes les barrières
vont s'abaisser toutes les frontières
vont se défaire les identités se diluer
et de l'époque où le citoyen politiques
préoccupés de l'avenir de son pays
s'inquiéter pour son avenir nous allons
passer à l'époque dans laquelle le
consommateur satisfaits se verra offrir
le meilleur produit au moindre coût par
une concurrence universel
c'était le rêve de la fin de l'histoire
c'était comme le disait fukuyama dans un
syntagme délicieusement vintage c'était
la victoire du magnétoscope et bien de
fait ça ne s'est pas tout à fait assez
comme ça ça ne s'est pas tout à fait
passé comme ça et nous vivons
aujourd'hui la fin de la fin de
l'histoire
nous vivons aujourd'hui ce que vous
voyez tous les jours dans vos journaux
sur vos chaînes de télévision la montée
de ces tensions économiques et
commerciales qui nous prouvent
quotidiennement que non les intérêts
particuliers ne se sont pas remis et que
non les frontières ne se sont pas
abaissés et que oui évidemment la
politique existe encore les américains
ont une politique économique et
commerciale extrêmement affirmé pour
défendre leurs intérêts
les chinois ont une politique
industrielle extrêmement extrêmement
agressive est forte et nous en europe
nous eh bien nous n'avons encore qu'une
doctrine de la concurrence vous l'avez
vu avec le dossier alsthom si mince on
pourrait revenir longtemps sur ce
rapprochement entre ces deux grandes
entreprises industrielles il y aurait
tellement à en dire sans doute ce
dossier n'était il pas bien ajustée sans
doute fallait-il le reprendre
le rééquilibrage il n'en reste pas moins
que tout le monde s'est rendu compte à
l'occasion de l'échec de la fusion entre
ses deux grandes entreprises
industrielles européennes que nous
étions en train de nous tirer des balles
dans le pied
nos entreprises doivent faire face à des
géants issus de ces grandes puissances
qui sont en situation de monopole sur
leur territoire de départ et qui sont
largement soutenues par des aides d'état
respectifs et nous face à ces géants
nous interdisons à nos propres
entreprises de se conforter les unes par
les autres de se rapprocher les unes des
autres et de faire en sorte qu'elle
devienne plus forte dans la compétition
mondiale
oui nous devons retrouver une vraie
stratégie industrielle et commerciale
oui nous devons assumer enfin que
l'europe doit d'abord défendre nos
entreprises et nos emplois
et oui nous devons assumer que l'europe
nous devons assumer que l'europe ne doit
pas être le seul endroit au monde où
l'on croit que le principal dans le
commerce et l'économie c'est de renoncer
à défendre ses propres intérêts nous ne
voulons pas nous replier entre quatre
murs nous sommes ici dans ce territoire
magnifique qui a vu la france rayonner
dans le monde entier
nous sommes ici au coeur d'un peuple
industrieux d'un peuple de commerçants
d'un peuple qui a conquis le monde par
l'excellence des savoir-faire qu'il a su
vendre partout sur tous les continents
du monde
nous n'avons pas pour but de construire
quatre murs entre lesquels mourir à
petit feu en omettant à l'écart de ce
monde qui avance récents nous nous
croyons à la force de nos entreprises
nous croyons à l'excellence de ses
savoir-faire qui peuvent encore marqué
tous les pays autour de nous nous
croyons cher guillaume au génie de ces
agriculteurs qui se sont transmis de
génération en génération des
savoir-faire magnifique qui
entretiennent des terroirs
exceptionnelle et qui ont su non
seulement transmettre cet héritage mais
l'actualiser le réinventer le moderniser
qui ont su se projeter dans l'avenir
non nous ne croyons pas contrairement à
ce que dit le ministre de l'agriculture
que l'avenir de l'agriculture ce soit de
retrouver les techniques de nos grands
parents
nous savons
que le génie nos agriculteurs peut
marquer l'actualité et le futur du monde
dans lequel nous sommes et nous croyons
d'ailleurs disons le en passant que
c'est aussi notre responsabilité à nous
la france nous sommes ici dans cette
terre ou montesquieu a inventé la
théorie des climats et oui les climats
existe bien et nous avons en france ce
climat incroyablement tempéré favorable
ce climat modéré que vous connaissez
bien dans cette région et qui permet à
la france de voir grandir et de voir
pousser les plus belles races d'élevage
les plus belles plantes à cultiver et
nous avons le devoir bien sûr de
continuer à soutenir cette agriculture
française qui n'est pas une agriculture
médiocre et pauvres qui au contraire est
l'une des dernières activités
économiques de notre pays qui soit
excédentaire commercialement une
agriculture qui exporte une agriculture
qui rayonne nous avons été nous avons
été un peu les seuls dans cette campagne
à défendre cette agriculture
à notre droite comme à notre gauche on
ne parle que de circuits courts de
petites quantités avec de grandes
qualités on ne parle que de bio bien sûr
tout cela est très important et bien sûr
il faut que nous puissions encourager
les circuits courts pour pouvoir faire
en sorte que dans nos cantines dans nos
écoles nos enfants puissent se nourrir
des produits cultivés localement mais
allez donc à cognac aller parler à
cognac de circuits courts aller parler à
cognac d'une agriculture qui se
contenterait de nourrir les alentours
aller parler à cognac aller parler à des
viticulteurs bordelais allaient parler
de ce que c'est qu'une agriculture
française qui renonceraient à exporter
et vous allez voir comment ils entendent
le discours que vous tenez sur cette
résignation et ce fatalisme auquel vous
voudriez nous condamnés
nous ne croyons pas contrairement au
rassemblement national nous ne croyons
pas à contrairement à la france est
soumise aux écologistes ne croyant pas
du tout qu'il faille renoncer à produits
qu'il faille renoncer à cultiver qu'il
faille commencer à inventer
qu'il faille recommencé à offrir au
monde entier ce que nous pouvons lui
apporter de meilleures et nous savons
que dans l'agriculture aussi en exporte
autant le cognac que l'on exporte des
airbus dans la discrétion
et pourtant avec la même efficacité et
avec quelle performance et avec quelle
fierté aussi
et nous ne voulons pas renoncer à sa
fierté mes chers amis pour que cette
compétition économique à laquelle nous
croyons pour que cette liberté d'échangé
est un sens pour que ce doux commerce
dont parlait encore monter ce que puisse
rapprocher les hommes encore faut-il que
les règles soient les mêmes pour tous
nous croyons à les changes
mais comment se fait-il que nous n'ayons
jamais réussi à obtenir
comment se fait-il que nous n'ayons
jamais cherché même parfois à obtenir ce
qui devrait être la condition minimale
dans tout les changes commerciale une
stricte réciprocité
il faut que les règles soient les mêmes
pour tous
le saviez vous c'est une statistique que
je ne cesse de répéter
d'ailleurs avec laurent ans sillonne la
france depuis des semaines maintenant il
doit plus en pouvoir de m'entendre
répéter les mêmes statistiques tout le
temps enfin il vaut mieux se répéter que
se contredire et quand on voit certains
qui sont entrés au gouvernement
aujourd'hui on se dit que c'est une
vertu qu'on ne veut pas leur envier et
puis vous savez il paraît qu'il faut
garder mon côté profs alors la pédagogie
c'est la répétition donc je me répète
donc le saviez vous en europe et c'est
très important de le comprendre parce
que ça dit tout en europe 20% du pib est
constituée par des marchés publics et
bien en europe 95% de ses marchés
publics sont ouverts aux acteurs
internationaux
nous sommes les seuls au monde à croire
à cette ouverture inconditionné nous
sommes les seuls au monde
arrivée de la fin de l'histoire les
marchés publics américains y sont
ouverts qu'à 30%
les marchés publics russes 0% les
marchés publics chinois 0%
comment est il acceptable qu'une
entreprise chinoise puisse prendre un
marché public en france et faire du
profit en france alors que jamais la
meilleure entreprise française ne pourra
prendre un marché public en chine et
faire du profit en chine
voilà le scandale actuel est bien face
face à cette situation nous avons une
solution magnifique et cette solution
c'est l'europe
bien souvent on entend dire que notre
problème c'est l'europe et parfois hélas
c'est vrai mais notre solution aussi
c'est ce que l'europe a construit notre
solution c'est ce marché européen
ce marché commun un extraordinaire
atouts dans la mondialisation
aujourd'hui ce marché commun est une
proie et une cible facile
mais demain il peut être si nous le
voulons il suffit de le vouloir un
levier formidable pour pouvoir obtenir
enfin cette réciprocité dont nous avons
besoin car nous en avons besoin
nous croyons à la force de l'entreprise
mais la meilleure équipe du monde si
elle rentre sur un terrain de football
dont le terrain n'est pas plat et où
l'arbitré corrompu est sûr de perdre le
match
eh bien nous sommes capables de gagner
la coupe du monde nous sommes aussi
capables de gagner ces combats là encore
faut-il que le terrain soit plat et que
l' arbitre applique les mêmes règles à
tous et pour l'obtenir enfin il faut
utiliser la force de ce marché commun
quand vous êtes c'est ce que les
britanniques découvrent aujourd'hui à
leurs dépens après que d'autres se sont
félicités du bric site qui change
aujourd'hui de discours quand vous êtes
un marché de quelques dizaines de
millions d'habitants une grande
puissance dans le monde peut facilement
vous contourner mais si vous voulez
échanger avec elle vous savez que ce
sera à ces conditions c'est ce que
vivent aujourd'hui les britanniques y
compris avec les américains c'est leur
amère déception il avait cru devenir
globale britten il avait cru pouvoir
nouer des accords favorable avec le
reste du monde
et bien aujourd'hui ils se rendent
compte que quand on est quelques
dizaines de millions d'habitants
on est contraint de se plier aux règles
qui nous sont imposées par de grandes
puissances mondiales
on peut aisément contourné un marché de
quelques dizaines d'amis deux millions
d'habitants
mais on ne peut pas contourner un marché
de 500 millions d'habitants on ne peut
pas contourner l'europe
et si l'europe se réveille quand
l'europe se réveillera alors elle sera
invincible
elle pourra dire à ceux qui voudront
échanger avec elle venez échanger avec
nous venaient proposer ce que vous avez
fermé nous nous voulons pouvoir avoir le
même accès à vos marchés venaient si les
règles sont les mêmes pour tous nous
sommes prêts à jouer le jeu mais que
chacun joue le jeu et quand l'europe le
demandera alors personne ne pourra
contourner ce que l'europe exigera voilà
ce qu'il nous faut obtenir
et voilà ce qu'il nous faudra obtenir
demain
et voilà cher guillaume en effet
pourquoi il est indispensable que nous
entrions nombreux au parlement européen
voilà pourquoi il est indispensable que
tu entres avec nos guillaume au
parlement européen pour une raison très
simple nous sommes membre d'une grande
famille politique européenne qui
s'appelle le ppe et bien c'est au sein
de cette grande famille politique que
cette réorientation dont l'europe a
tellement besoin pourra et pourra seul
s'opérer c'est au sein de cette grande
famille politique que la voix de la
france pourra être entendue c'est au
sein de cette famille politique qu'il
faudra peser de tout notre poids et
c'est pourquoi il faudra être nombreux
pour pouvoir faire entendre une voix
crédible une voix audible qu'il dira que
l'europe
enfin doit se doter d'une stratégie que
l'europe enfin doit rompre avec cette
naïveté qui nous a fait tant de mal
encore faut-il pour cela que la france
soit crédible
pourquoi n'avons nous pas réussi à nous
faire entendre si longtemps de nos
partenaires européens
parce que nos partenaires européens
depuis bien longtemps
on fait les réformes qu'il fallait pour
se mettre au niveau de ce marché commun
que nous avons construit lorsque nous
sommes passés à un marché unique
lorsque nous avons fait la monnaie
unique l'allemagne faisait les grandes
réformes dont elle bénéficie aujourd'hui
et nous on faisait les 35 heures ça
pouvait pas marcher comme ça ça pouvait
pas durer longtemps et aujourd'hui nous
sommes citoyens de ce pays qui est
actuellement à la dernière place en
europe en matière de déficit public pour
la première fois depuis le début du
projet européen pour la première fois
emmanuel macron a mis notre pays
au 28e rang sur 28 en matière de
déficits publics
nous sommes depuis des années
déficitaires commercialement depuis des
années nous consommons plus que nous
produisons depuis des années nous
alimentons notre consommation
d'aujourd'hui par le poids des déficits
accumulés qui vont peser sur les épaules
des générations qui viendront et nous
sommes aujourd'hui inaudible dans le
débat européen
parce que lorsque nous avons demandé à
nos partenaires européens de protéger un
peu ce marché ils nous auront ils nous
ont répondu commencé par faire les
réformes qui vous permettront d'être
efficace commencer par renouer avec la
compétitivité commencer par vous
remettre en condition pour pouvoir de
nouveau exporter pourquoi aurions nous à
subir le poids de vos fragilité et nous
pouvons comprendre c'est vrai que
peut-être il est eu du mal à nous juger
très crédible quand vous êtes emmanuel
macron et que vous êtes le président qui
a réussi à mettre la france au dernier
rang des pays européens en matière de
déficit public derrière la grèce
derrière l'italie quand vous êtes
emmanuel macron êtes vous êtes le
président du pays qui prélèvent les
charges sociales et fiscales les plus
élevés au monde et qu'ensuite vous
écrivez une lettre européens en leur
disant chers amis européens
je vais vous expliquer à quoi devrait
ressembler l'europe
quand vous êtes le dernier de la classe
et que vous écrivez à vos petits
camarades en leur disant est ce que vous
voudriez pas commencer à me ressembler
un peu ça devient pénible de vous voir
toujours devant on comprend que les
autres vous regardez vous disent mais
qu'est ce que vous êtes pour nous donner
des leçons
alors oui c'est vrai oui nous sommes de
cette famille politique qui n'a pas
renoncé à dire que la france avait
besoin de faire des choix courageux pour
retrouver confiance en son avenir
oui nous avons besoin que l'europe
évolué oui nous avons besoin que nos
partenaires fassent leur part du chemin
mais oui nous avons aussi notre part du
chemin à faire
eh oui si nous voulons être crédibles
dans le débat européen il nous faudra
aussi avec l'exigence nécessaire prendre
les décisions qui s'imposent pour
pouvoir retrouver cet oxygène dont nous
avons tellement besoin
depuis le début de cette campagne je
l'entend partout en france tant de chefs
d'entreprise qui ont le sentiment
qu'aujourd'hui créer un emploi est un
exploit infinie temps d'agriculteurs qui
ont le sentiment que pèse sur des normes
toujours plus compliqué des contrôles
toujours plus lourd au point qu'ils ont
le sentiment d'être quasiment traités
comme des délinquants tous les jours
dans d'artisans de commerçants qui sont
piégés par ces règles qui sont parfois
les derniers à se payer de leurs
salariés
parce qu'ils n'arrivent pas à s'en
sortir tant de gens qui travaillent et
qui ne s'en sortent pas qui travaillent
et qu'ils n'arrivent pas à joindre les
deux bouts
parce que le travail ne paye pas parce
que nous avons le sentiment au fond de
cette asphyxie dans laquelle nous sommes
piégés et parce que cette asphyxie aussi
bien monsieur hollande que son ancien
ministre monsieur macron ne cesse de
répondre par toujours plus de dépenses
publiques toujours plus de complexité
le nombre de fonctionnaires on l'a
appris il hier a encore augmenté et je
ne dis pas cela parce qu'il faudrait
persécuter les fonctionnaires au
contraire j'en suis un et je sais
combien les enseignants de notre pays
souffre d'abord de la crise que notre
éducation nationale traverse et d'avoir
le sentiment d'être au front dans un
combat déprimant contre une sorte
d'impuissance collective dans laquelle
ils sont piégés à cause d'une
administration qui n'a pas su se
réorienter qui n'a pas su se réformer et
je sais aussi combien il est douloureux
pour les enseignants français
pour les fonctionnaires de france qui
font vivre les services publics de
travailler à eux aussi et parfois de
travailler beaucoup et d'être au front
face à toutes les difficultés sociales
que traverse notre pays est pourtant de
ne pas s'en sortir de ne pas pouvoir
joindre les deux bouts
quand vous êtes enseignant à paris quand
vous êtes enseignant dans le centre
ville d'une grande métropole française
vous ne pouvez plus vous loger là où
vous enseigner oui nous avons besoin de
retrouver cet oxygène qui fera que le
travail paie y compris dans nos services
publics
et oui nous avons besoin de réformer
notre état parce que depuis de longues
années les français le voient très bien
le poids de la fiscalité n'a cessé
d'augmenter le poids des charges n'a
cessé de s'alourdir et les services
publics à la fin n'ont cessé de se
dégrader de se complexifier de
s'éloigner de cette france rurale de
cette france périphérique de cette
france des oubliés oui on peut faire
mieux avec moins
et oui on doit faire mieux avec moins et
nous sommes de ceux qui n'ont pas
relancé à lotbinière et nous ne nous
laisserons pas faire la leçon par ses
responsables politiques issus de la
droite qui mène aujourd'hui une
politique de gauche
il explique que nous sommes la france du
trocadéro que nous sommes la droite du
trocadéro eh bien nous n'avons pas
renoncé c'est vrai à cette droite qui
est fidèle à son message fidèle à ses
convictions fidèle à son projet fidèle à
ses électeurs
et s'ils veulent nous reprocher cette
fidélité là elle est pour nous notre
honneur et nous continuerons de dire à
temps et à contretemps à ce gouvernement
qui n'a rien fait pour sortir la france
des difficultés structurelles qu'il
connaît nous continuerons de dire que
l'essentiel du travail est devant et que
l'essentiel de ce travail ce sera notre
responsabilité
ensemble d'apporter à la france
l'alternative qui pourra le réaliser
enfin car oui ce défi est devant nous
[Applaudissements]
c'est la bataille de l'économie et de
l'emploi c'est la bataille pour
retrouver un équilibre dans notre
société mais retrouver un équilibre dans
notre société c'est aussi relevé tous
les autres camps défis qui nous
attendent
le défi écologique bien sûr et par où
passe t'il sinon par le fait de
rééquilibrer la mondialisation par où
passe le fait de retrouver un équilibre
par note pour notre environnement
sinon par le fait de pouvoir enfin
réapprendre à produire ce que nous
consommons aujourd'hui du parlait de
sylviculture chéri dit aujourd'hui en
coupe du chêne dans les forêts
françaises
ce chêne on l'envoie en chine pour
devenir du parquet ou du mobilier et on
le ramène en france pour que vous
puissiez lâcheté sous forme de parquet
ou de mobilier est ce que ce monde est
sérieux comme tu le demandes est chez
riot est ce que ce nouveau monde est
sérieux
bien sûr que non il nous faut retrouver
un équilibre retrouvé un équilibre cela
suppose de réapprendre à produire ce que
nous consommons
quand nous achetons de l'agneau new
zeland est vendu sur nos étalages de
supermarché à côté de l'agneau français
l'agneau français abattu trois semaines
avant d'être vendus la nuit aux néo
zélandais a battu des mois avant d'être
vendus cette année aux néo zélandais il
a traversé le monde pour arriver dans
votre assiette il a fait dix-huit mille
cinq cents kilomètres avant d'arriver
jusqu'à vous et il coûte moins cher que
l'agneau français pourquoi parce qu'il a
été cultivé élevé selon des standards
qui n'ont rien à voir avec les normes
que nous imposons à nos agriculteurs cet
agneau est arrivé sans payer les mêmes
charges sans subir les mêmes normes sans
respecter les mêmes règles et il est
vendu là après dix huit mille cinq cents
kilomètres de trajet il a vécu me disait
un éleveur ovin récemment il a vécu plus
longtemps mort que vivant cet agneau néo
zélandais il a traversé la planète
et nous laissons ce faire ce monde de
flux perpétuel qui nous vite de notre
capacité de produire et qui déstabilise
le monde dans lequel nous sommes
aujourd'hui
et ensuite on explique aux salariés
français qui a besoin de sa voiture pour
faire 5 km pour aller travailler que
c'est lui qui est responsable de la
catastrophe écologique que c'est lui qui
est responsable de la construit ma tite
[Applaudissements]
alors mes chers amis c'est l'un des
grands défis de l'europe il faut
redonner un équilibre à la
mondialisation en réapprenant à produire
ce que nous consommons il suffira pas
comme le propose la république en marche
ah ça on reconnaît que la gauche n'est
pas morte il suffira pas puisque c'est
l'un de leurs grands projets dans le
programme de la république en marche
grand problème grandes solutions grandes
solutions grande dépense bien sûr la
gauche a des habits nouveau mais en fait
elle n'a pas changé
dépenser 1000 milliards d'euros chers
amis c'est le projet on sait pas trop
pourquoi faire le projet c'est la
dépense dépenser 1000 milliards d'euros
comme si ça pouvait être résorbé la
catastrophe écologique
chers amis s'il suffisait d'additionner
les dépenses publiques pour remédier au
problème climatique la france serait un
paradis climatique
en vérité la france mais la france n'est
pas un paradis climatique c'est juste un
enfer fiscal mais ça c'est un autre
sujet bref rééquilibrer la
mondialisation rééquilibrer la
mondialisation c'est aussi faire face
aux défis migratoires qui est devant
nous et non pas derrière nous laurent on
vous en reparlera mieux que moi mais ce
défi migratoire fondamental il est la
condition d'un équilibre retrouvé
et c'est face à ce défi migratoire que
nous voulons que l'europe agisse car oui
nous sommes de ceux qui croient à
l'europe quand elle nous permet d'être
plus efficaces ensemble que si nous
étions seuls isolés face à l'ampleur de
ce défi qui peut croire sérieusement que
la grèce tout seul défendra ses dizaines
d'îles et qui peut croire que si un pays
européen est défaillant face à l'ampleur
de ce défi nous ne serons pas tous
affectés
quand l'italie ferme ses frontières
aujourd'hui les migrants passent par
l'espagne et c'est par les pyrénées
qu'ils arrivent aujourd'hui en france
alors oui c'est vrai nous avons besoin
d'une europe qui puisse de nouveau
assumer de maîtriser ses frontières face
aux flux migratoires pour
pouvoir accueillir vraiment ceux qui ont
besoin de notre solidarité nous voulons
bien accueillir et la ville fait partie
de ce que la civilisation européenne a
produit de plus beau nous voulons bien
accueillir mais nous ne voulons pas
subir et c'est tout autre chose
d'accueillir c'est tout autre chose
d'ouvrir la porte à celui qui vous a
demandé d'entrée et qui a besoin de
votre aide
que la voir sa porte enfoncée tous les
jours c'est tout autre chose d'ouvrir la
porte à quelqu'un qui vous demande
d'entrer pour l'accueillir entre vaut
mieux est de ne plus avoir de mur oui
nous voulons que l'europe puisse
maîtriser ses frontières et ce grand
défi là aussi est devant nous ce défi il
est nécessaire si nous voulons éviter de
continuer de produire du malheur à
grande échelle malheur pour nos sociétés
si profondément facturé malheur pour
tous ces jeunes venus d'afrique qui se
laisse entendre le miroir aux alouettes
d'un eldorado qu'ils ne trouveront pas
s'il arrive en europe
nous ne pourrons redonner un avenir à
l'afrique nous ne pourrons redonner un
équilibre monde de demain que si nous
savons maîtriser de nouveaux nos
frontières et c'est un défi majeur aussi
pour que nous puissions retrouver cet
équilibre dont nos pays ont besoin car
le défi est devant nous le défi c'est
celui de l'intégration
le défi c'est celui de redevenir une
nation
le défi c'est celui de retrouver le sens
de ce qui nous relient les uns aux
autres une civilisation
voilà peut-être le dernier est le
premier thème le plus important d'entre
eux tous sans doute celui que nous avons
porté dans ce débat avec force depuis le
départ
l'europe de redécouvrir ce qu'elle est
l'europe ce n'est pas d'abord des
traités l'europe ce n'est pas d'abord
des administrations l'europe ce n'est
pas d'abord un projet c'est d'abord une
civilisation c'est d'abord un mérite à
halle
c'est d'abord une histoire l'europe
c'est ce petit miracle discret de la
raison qui naît lorsque dans les cités
grecques des hommes et des femmes
décident qu'il ne leur suffira plus
d'expliquer le monde avec des
mythologies mais qu'ils veulent
désormais le logo ce qu'ils veulent
désormais la logique
l'explication rationnelle l'europe c'est
cette exigence de rationalité qui fait
que du logos nous passons au dialogue os
et que le dialogue devient la
délibération collective par laquelle
nous écrivons ensemble notre avenir au
lieu de le subir c'est la démocratie
et lorsque nous parlons ensemble comme
ce soir
dans cette salle dans l'hémicycle de
l'assemblée nationale ou du sénat comme
dans le plus simple conseil municipal
lorsque nous délibérons nous sommes les
enfants des grecs
l'europe c'est bien sûr le sens de
l'autorité de l'état c'est le sens de la
respublica c'est le sens de la chose de
tous c'est cette égalité devant la loi
qui fait que par le monde romain
diffusée dans tout l'espace latin nous
découvrons qu'il n'y a pas de liberté
s'il n'y a pas d'autorité et si nous
sommes aujourd'hui les premiers à dire
que nous ne pouvons plus subir ce chaos
qui sèment le désordre dans nos centres
villes semaine après semaine
si nous sommes les premiers à dire que
nos désaccords doivent se dire dans le
cadre démocratique de la vie
républicaine c'est parce que nous sommes
les héritiers des romains et l'europe
enfin pourquoi ne pas le dire pourquoi
avoir tant tardé à la nommer c'est cette
magnifique histoire de la tradition
chrétienne qui apportait pour le monde
le sens de la dignité humaine
oui voilà ce que l'europe doit dire
voilà ce que l'europe doit être voilà ce
que l'europe doit dire au monde de
demain
voilà ce que l'europe doit dire dans
cette tentation qui traversent notre
monde
ce que l'europe doit dire dans la
tentation de traiter l'humain comme une
marchandise parmi d'autres lorsqu'on
propose de louer ce par quoi une femme
peut donner la vie
lorsqu'on propose de manipuler l'humain
pour faire de l'eugénisme l'occasion de
rentrer dans nos corps comme sur le
nouveau terrain de compétition où
l'exigence de performance viendra faire
ses ravages
l'humain n'est pas humain parce qu'il
est fort mais parce qu'il est vulnérable
voilà ce que l'europe a su découvrir
voilà ce qu'elle doit dire au monde
l'europe a inventé la déclaration des
droits de l'homme et du citoyen qui sait
que cette dignité de l'homme est une
dignité inaliénable et que rien ne peut
la lui retirer et devant les tentations
techniciste devant la tentation
transhumanistes devant cet empire
américain qui a aujourd'hui la
possibilité de vendre des enfants sur
catalogue devant cet empire chinois qui
a annoncé récemment que de bébé venait
de naître génétiquement modifiées nous
devons faire entendre cette voix de
l'europe
cette voie d'une civilisation qui peut
encore dire au monde le sens de cette
juste mesure le sens de cette modération
le sens de cette passion de l'humain
rien n'est beau
rien mais bodies est un ancien maire de
bordeaux qui s'appelait michel de
montaigne rien et beau comme la forme de
l'humaine condition que chacun d'entre
nous porte en lui la forme de l'humaine
condition voilà ce que l'europe a
supporté montaigne était un grand
lecteur des grecs et un grand lecteur
des latins montaigne et celui sans doute
par qui s'est condensée cet héritage
commun montaigne est celui par qui nous
pouvons redécouvrir la jubilation de la
conversation de cet art de la conférence
qui fait aussi la saveur de notre vie
politique
montaigne est sans doute ce grand esprit
européen qui dans l'enquêté dans l'étude
et dans l'échangé dans les essais
montrent à quel point nous sommes nous
mêmes lorsque nous savons nous nourrir
de tout ce qui nous a précédé pour
pouvoir écrire les plus belles pages que
nous avons inventé
voilà ce qui fait leur profond et cette
europe là chers amis cette europe là
nous en aurons besoin pour relever les
plus grande bataille de demain et l'une
d'entre elles se nomment lutte contre le
terrorisme islamiste lutte contre
l'islam radical qui gangrène notre
société lutte contre le communautarisme
on le dit trop souvent l'europe c'est la
paix mais la paix est aujourd'hui
menacée elle est aujourd'hui fragile
menacée lorsque à la terrasse des cafés
des individus innocents sont tués
menacée lorsque certains doivent
pratiquer leur culte sous protection
militaire simplement parce qu'ils sont
de confession juive
menacé par tout ce qui fait les nouveaux
visages de la guerre qui traverse notre
pays face à ce défi majeur il faut des
réponses sécuritaires il faut des
réponses judiciaires mais il faut aussi
cette réponse fondamentale qui consiste
à redire ce qu'est la civilisation
européenne pour pouvoir de nouveau la
partager à tous les jeunes qui
grandissent en france et dont beaucoup
hélas grandissent sans se reconnaître
français sans ce savoir enfants de cette
europe à tous ces jeunes là
il faut donner quelque chose à aimer il
faut donner la france a aimé il faut
donner l'europe en héritage et voilà ce
qui fait le défi devant lequel nous
sommes aujourd'hui
voilà pourquoi il faut savoir nommer
l'europe voilà pourquoi il faut savoir
la dir et les met de nouveau alors chers
amis devant tous ces grands défis devant
tous ces défis majeurs nous avons besoin
de vous vous comprenez l'ampleur
incroyable de ces enjeux auxquels nous
sommes confrontés malgré cette ampleur
incroyable on voudrait nous priver de ce
débat si nécessaire on voudrait nous
expliquer qu'au fond il serait encore
temps de vivre une nouvelle élection
contre contre marine le pen ou contre
emmanuel macron ils ne sont d'accord que
pour nous dire qu'il s'agit aujourd'hui
d'être contre emmanuel macron rentrer
dans ce débat en disant je suis contre
marine le pen marine le pen rentrer dans
ce débat en disant je veux battre
emmanuel macron eh bien nous n'avons
qu'un seul but c'est de refonder
l'europe pour pouvoir rétablir la france
nous n'en pouvons plus de ces élections
contre 90 pouvant plus de ces élections
par défaut nous ne voulons plus de ces
élections où on n'a qu'à choisir entre
le pire et le pire
nous voulons et je vais vous le dire ce
soir ce qui me marque le plus la
première réunion de cette campagne celle
qui a eu lieu tout juste après mon
investiture à l'époque où les vents
contraires étaient encore bien fort un
journaliste était dans la salle de cette
petite réunion tout simple et il a écrit
un article dans lequel il disait j'ai vu
quelque chose d'étonnant
j'ai vu de la joie chers amis nous n'en
pouvons plus des élections triste et ce
soir ce qui me marque le plus c'est ce
dont vous avez tous parler à la tribune
avant moi c'est cette joie nous voulons
voter pour pour l'europe que nous
voulons pour la france que nous aimons
pour pouvoir refonder l'europe et
pouvoir rétablir la france et nous avons
besoin de vous pour cela nous avons
besoin de votre joie nous avons besoin
de votre voix et ensemble oui ensemble
nous allons faire la surprise
le 26 mai vive l'europe et vive la
france
[Applaudissements]
j'ai oublié de le citer mais
applaudissent et notre directeur de
campagne geoffroy merci françois xavier
merci je voudrais saluer la présence
parmi nous ce soir d'un acteur essentiel
pour cette région
il est maire du bouscat et il a fait il
ya quelques semaines l'unanimité pour
devenir le nouveau président de la
métropole de bordeaux vous pouvez
applaudir patrick bobet sa présence
patrick bobet sa présence ici est
essentiel pour nous vous êtes restés
fidèles à notre famille politique est
ici sans doute plus qu'ailleurs
vous savez que ça veut dire quelque
chose merci beaucoup d'être parmi nous
ce soir
il est en train de réussir le pari de la
reconstruction de la droite
il n'est pas seulement courageux qui est
aussi audacieux vous pouvez ovationné
laurent wauquiez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
que
de la joie ses bottes conclure à main
discours en parlant de la joie en
politique et/ou savez ce qu'il ne touche
le plus dans cette campagne avec
françois-xavier quand on vient ensemble
meeting après meeting avec à votre
rencontre
c'est ce sentiment qui est notre
meilleure récompense que vous avez
retrouvé de l'envié que vous avez
retrouvé de l'enthousiasmé qu'on a
retrouvé du plaisir qu'on a retrouvé
cette volonté qui nous unit quelles que
soient les différences qui sont entre
nous deux d'abord porté les convictions
et la vision commune de la france et de
l'europe qui est la nôtre je vous avais
promis qu'on retrouverait ça je vous
avais promis que notre reconstruction
nous amènerait là et ce qui est sans
doute là qui le plus fort pour nous de
cette campagne européenne
c'est d'avoir réussi à retrouver d'abord
cette fierté de nos valeurs des
convictions de la droite et du centre et
de l'avoir fait en se rassemblant et on
se retrouve en ensemble merci à tous de
nous avoir un psy et de porter cette
campagne et les dé prendre soin xavier
dans ce moment yvan toi qui est l'ami
fidèle et loyal dans cette région où j'y
pensais quand guillaume liste et chaque
mot ou chaque département est le nom
d'une page d'aventuré d'histoire à lui
tout seul que l'on mailles du béarn
jusqu'aux confins du poitou charentes
patrick roy qui incarne la loyauté la
constance dans cette région où je sais
il ya parfois eu des vents contraires et
où il ya parfois eu beaucoup de troubles
et je suis d'une profonde reconnaissance
à chacun d'entre vous d'être resté aux
côtés de notre famille politique dans
cette période en une reconnaissance qui
va du premier de nos députés didier en
passant par nos sénateurs nombreux par
nos élus régionaux départementaux
municipaux mais jusqu à chacun d'entre
vous qui êtes les militants de notre
famille politique et qui nous rappeler
une chose en politique les âmes de son
à fendre en politique les âmes mortes ne
sont pas à acheter
une des choses que je reproche sans
doute le plus à en marche c'est d'avoir
constitué au fond une politique faite de
mercenaires où l'on débauche les gens en
leur offrant des postes aux républicains
dans la droite et le centre
les armes ne sont pas achetées et je
veux devant vous exprimer ma gratitude à
françois xavier pour ceux d'entre vous
qui ne l'aviez pas écouté jusque là
maintenant vous savez vous savez
pourquoi j'ai fait ce choix
vous savez pourquoi j'ai tenu à faire ce
choix soit qu'il n'a pas été toujours
facile au début
à faire partager parce qu'il était
surprenant mais en politique les joies
face ils ne sont jamais les bons choix
et le moment je savais et où j'ai su que
c'était évidemment le bon pari est plus
qu'un pari où c'était la seule manière
de tirer la politique vers le haut c'est
quand il ya eu ce débat france
télévisions et où chacune des têtes de
listes devaient exhumé un objet qui
incarnait sa vision profonde de ce qu'il
voulait faire en politique
le tête de liste du rassemblement
national avait sorti une passoire rouge
1 têtes de liste dont je ne connais même
plus le nom avait exhumé une paire de
menottes sur laquelle il s'était
astreint à coller des petits
autocollants jaunes la tête de liste en
mars c'est sans doute d'ailleurs une des
dernières fois où ils ont accepté de lui
laisser la parole avait sorti une boîte
de piment d'espelette et françois-xavier
lui avait sorti un livre et qu'elle
livre l'iliade d'homère merci à françois
xavier de redonner de la dignité et du
sens à la politique
nous le faisons ensemble est dit nous
faisons ensemble avec cpnt nous le
faisons ensemble avec hervé morin et
n'oubliez jamais seul à la droite
rassemble quand elle assume ses valeurs
et ses idées la droite quand elle baisse
le regard quand elle marche à l'ombre
quand elle s'excuse
elle ne rassemble pas ce que nous avons
fait dans cette campagne c'est que nous
avons réussi à rassembler il y a deux
jours nous étions tous ensemble avec
valérie pécresse avec gérard larcher
avec bruno retailleau avec christian
jacob
avec tous les parlementaires et tout le
monde est d'être ensemble
et bien c'est cette image que j'aime
pour notre famille politique et avons
expliqué ce message que françois-xavier
veut porter avec toute l'équipe
je voudrais juste m'arrêter sur quelque
chose qui est tout à la fois extrêmement
révélateur est assez choquant la façon
dont au fond le président de la
république le premier ministre
la totalité des membres de son
gouvernement insultes régulièrement la
france de droite le premier ministre
encore très régulièrement s'en est pris
vous l'avais dit à la france du
trocadéro il y a hier ils s'en prenaient
en expliquant la droite qui se paye de
mots mais quelle étrange comportement
qu'elle est trans premier ministre que
celui ci qui donne tellement de leçons à
tout le monde lui qui a rejoint le
président de la république en étant
quelqu'un à l'arrière d'une voiture avec
une couverture sur la tête
conduite par monsieur benalla et
malheureusement l'anecdote est véritable
quelle étrange premier ministre et
qu'elle est trans président de la
république que celui qui prédestine aux
destinées de la france et qui croient
qu'on peut le faire
en insultant ceux qui ne partagent pas
vos idées qu'elle est trans président de
la république que celui qui insulte
régulièrement le peuple de la droite et
du centre
quelle étrange premier ministre qui dit
ne pas aimer la droite trocadéro mais
s'il n'aime pas la droite trocadéro
c'est parce qu'il n'aime pas la droite
du tout c'est parce qu'il n'y a plus
rien en lui de droite c'est parce que
tout ce qu'ils font depuis deux ans ne
correspond pas aux valeurs de la droite
et du centre
voilà ce qui gêne en réalité le premier
ministre parce que quand on est de
droite
on a le courage de baisser la dépense
publique et de réduire le nombre de
fonctionnaires pas ceux qui sont dans
les services publics mais ceux qui
aboutissent à cette bureaucratie qui
petit à petit est en train d'étouffer
notre pays sous le poids des normes des
contraintes et de l'absurdité que
dénonçait déjà pop ville quand on est de
droite
on ne nie pas l'existence d'une culture
française comme l'a fait le président de
la république on ne va pas dans un pays
comme l'algérie en expliquant que la
france n'aurait commis que des crimes
contre l'humanité et en humiliant ainsi
notre pays de l'autre côté de la
méditerranée
quand on est de droite on ne dit pas
comme l'a fait la tête de liste en
marche que le voile islamique n'a pas de
différence de nature avec les soi-disant
fistules qu'aurait portée nos
grands-mères en allant dans les églises
et en ne comprenant pas ainsi la
nécessité du combat que nous avions
amené quand on est de droite
on a du respect pour ceux qui vous ont
précédés pour ceux qui ont travaillé et
qui l'on fait souvent dans des
conditions qui étaient bien plus
difficile que celle de notre génération
quand on est de droite on ne dit pas que
les retraités sont des privilégiés comme
l'a fait le président de la république
et on ne leur prend pas huit milliards
d'euros en deux ans quand on est de
droite on n'accepte pas de faire rentrer
année après année plus d'immigrés alors
que nos capacités d'intégration sont
dépassés quand on est de droite on ne
met pas sur sa liste quelqu'un comme
pascal durand en position éligible qui a
osé dire et comparer un terroriste
palestinien nelson mandela pour en faire
l'éloge quel trouble des repères et
quels troubles de la vision et enfin mes
amis et dans cette région vous le savez
plus que
le monde quand on est de droite sa liste
n'est pas soutenu par cohn bendit
elisabeth guigou ségolène royal est
quelqu'un comme pascal canfin
tout ceci ressemble de plus en plus à
une nouvelle majorité de gauche
plurielle donc plus qu'à une liste de
droite
cette liste n'est pas de droite cette
liste ne correspond pas aux valeurs de
la droite et du centre
et je vous demande de le dire autour de
vous que tous ceux qui en france partage
les idées de la droite et du centre
fasse le choix de la seule liste qui est
un choix clairement pour l'europe et qui
le fait en défendant les valeurs de la
droite et du centre c'est celle des
républicains oui notre liste croix dans
l'europe
notre liste croire dans la vision de
notre liste croient plus que jamais dans
la nécessité d'une europe une europe qui
protège nos frontières une europe qui
défendent notre identité face à
l'islamisme
une europe qui acceptent le bras de fer
face à l'été face aux états unis et à la
chine une europe des projets l'europe
que nous aimons cette europe
ça n'est incontestablement pas celle de
la voie du rassemblement national et de
marine le pen
pourquoi est-ce que je combats marine le
pen dans cette élection je la combat
pour une seule raison c'est parce que ce
qu'elle porte c'est un projet de
déconstruction de l'europe
je la combat pour une seule raison c'est
parce que ce qu'elle porte c'est un
projet de déconstruction de l'euro et
j'invite chacun de nos compatriotes à
regarder ce qui se passe de l'autre côté
de la manche et à comprendre que ce
projet serait sans doute la pire erreur
historique pour notre pays
au royaume uni ce sont des gens qui ont
voté en écoutant exactement les mêmes
discours que ceux de marine le pen et
qui se réveille ensuite en se disant
mais comment avons nous pu plonger notre
pays dans un tel chaos dans un tel chaos
et dans cette campagne il ya quelque
chose qui est très marquant les extrêmes
se retrouvent et marine le pen est
maintenant soutenue par toute une partie
des élus qui viennent de l'extrême
gauche et de mélenchon et de la france
insoumise et cela nous rappelle une
seule chose mais que nous ne devons
jamais oublier
marine le pen n'est pas de droite marine
le pen est juste des extrêmes de tous
les extrêmes c'est la seule chose qui la
caractérise elle est l'incarnation de
cette volonté de rassembler l'extrême
droite et l'extrême gauche il n'y a rien
pour nous qui correspondent aux chemins
qui peuvent être les nôtres mais cette
voie n'est pas non plus celle d'emmanuel
macron emmanuel macron propose toujours
plus de l'europe qui n'a pas marché
l'europe de la technocratie l'europe de
l'élargissement l'europe multiculturelle
l'europe qui ne comprend pas qu'il faut
retrouver des projets et non des normes
l'europe qui s'épuise dans
l'élargissement et surtout lui qui se
prétendent être un grand européen
comment at il pu ainsi isoler la france
jamais sans doute depuis la seconde
guerre mondiale la relation franco
allemande n'a été aussi abîmé
jamais depuis la seconde guerre mondiale
une chancelière allemande n'a utilisé
des termes aussi durs pour décrire la
réalité de la capacité travail qu'elle
avait avec un président de la république
qu'elle ne comprenait pas et avec lequel
elle n'arrivait pas à avancer
quand angela merkel dit qu'elle a des
relations conflictuelles avec notre
président de la république jamais ça
n'est arrivé dans l'histoire des
relations franco allemandes de gaulle et
adenauer n'aurait jamais utilisé ce
terme
giscard d'estaing et schmitt cela ne
leur venaient même pas la tête
françois mitterrand et helmut kohl avait
conscience de leurs responsabilités eux
qui étaient pourtant si différents et il
avait pu travailler ensemble chirac et
schröder
on devrait ensemble nicolas sarkozy
angela merkel ont travaillé en confiance
françois hollande et en gala merkel ont
travaillé en confiance c'est la première
fois qu'un président de la république
abymes à ce point et l'europe et la
relation franco-allemande et pourquoi
c'est grave
pas parce que nous devons être tout le
temps d'accord avec l'allemagne mais
parce que si la france et l'allemagne ne
se mettent pas d'accord
rien ne peut avancer en europe paraît il
se prétend européens mais dans quel état
va-t-il laisser l'europe
il a fragmenté la france et il est en
train de fragmenter l'europe
il nous a mis à dos l'allemagne il nous
a mis à dos tous les peuples d'europe
centrale
il nous a mis à dos les pays de la
baltique en leur faisant la leçon il
nous a mis à dos l'italie il nous a mis
à dos les pays du benelux jamais sans
doute dans l'histoire européenne
la voix de la france a pesé aussi peu et
nous n'avons été aussi isolé et bien je
vous le dis le vote utile pour l'europe
c'est le vote pour les républicains
pour l'union de la droite et du centre
pour le parti populaire européen
[Applaudissements]
l'europe
que font les pères fondateurs
quand ils choisissent un symbole il met
sur ce drapeau quoi les étoiles de la
couronne de la vierge
c'est notre symbole c'est ce drapeau
c'est le drapeau européen
ou de gaulle et adenauer décide de se
retrouver au moment où ils veulent
sceller la réentendre franco-allemande
et bâtir la possibilité de donner un
nouvel élan en europe pas à bruxelles
pas à berlin pas à part et ils le font
devant la cathédrale de reims
devant cette statue admirable de lens au
sourire qui avait été détruite par les
bombardements allemands et il signifie
dans ce moment là que c'est au coeur de
ce que l'histoire européenne a de mieux
celle de ses racines chrétiennes qu'ils
vont édifier la réconciliation franco
allemande
voilà ce qu'ils font et ce qu'ils font
l'un et l'autre ce qu'on fait les pères
fondateurs ceux qui notamment à travers
monnaie ont grandi à l'ombre de cette
région et bien ce qu'ils font c'est un
projet de civilisation
une civilisation ce qu'ils font ça n'est
pas une construction administrative ils
veulent porter quoi ils veulent porter
cette idée qu au lendemain de la seconde
guerre mondiale la voix de l'europe
n'est pas éteinte qu'elle peut connaître
un souffle pourquoi êtes vous là au fond
parce que chacun d'entre nous nous
sommes habités par la même question
allons-nous devoir changer de mode de
vie
allons-nous quitté le train de
l'histoire nous qui l'avons fait pendant
tant de siècles
sommes nous condamnés à laisser à nos
enfants un continent qui reculent allons
nous assister maintenant spectateurs au
fait que ce sera tout à la fois google
et les dirigeants chinois qui vont
dicter ce que sera l'avenir de mes deux
enfants louise et baptiste est ce cela
ce destin que nous voulons ou est-ce
qu'au contraire ne sommes nous pas là
parce que nous sommes convaincus que
tout ce que nous sommes
permet un avenir à condition que nous
l'assumons et que nous en retrouverons
la fierté une civilisation l'europe
encore tente à dire pour la marche du
monde
mais qu'est ce que c'est qu'une
civilisation quand romulus fondre sommes
que fait-il il trace un sillon
et parce sion ils marquent clairement
les limites de la cité et il dit que
c'est lui qui décidera qui rentre ou qui
ne rentrent pas une civilisation c'est
d'abord des frontières ce sont des
limites
pourquoi avons nous affaiblit l'europe
parce que nous nous sommes trop élargi
il faut mettre un terme à
l'élargissement et c'est sans doute une
de nos différences majeures majeur avec
le programme des manuels macron emmanuel
macron accepte d'ouvrir les négociations
avec l'albanie en juin il a expliqué que
la roumanie et la bulgarie devait
rentrer le plus vite possible dans
l'espace schengen et il a dit à trieste
que tous les pays des balkans avait et
devait rentrer dans l'union européenne
rapidement nos chacune de nos têtes de
listes chacune de nos figures dans nos
régions et sur la liste s'engage à une
chose ils voteront pendant la totalité
de leurs mandats contre toute décision
qui ouvrirait la voie à un élargissement
supplémentaires avoir des frontières et
les connaître cela suppose ensuite bien
sûr de savoir bien défendre c'est même
la première vocation de ce qu'on attend
d'une construction politique
montesquieu l'avait d'ailleurs
parfaitement compris dans la filiation
mais je ne peux rien dire devant
françois xavier de obs la première
vocation du politique c'est d'abord de
protéger
c'est notre premier devoir aujourd'hui
nous ne protégeons pas il nous ne
contrôlons pas nos frontières est-ce
qu'elle arrivait le monde va mieux mais
c'est tout l'inversé
comment ne pas comprendre au contraire
que tous ces drames humains dans la
méditerranée auquel personne ne peut
rester insensible sont nourris par ces
faux espoirs que nous faisons lever ou
nous donnons le sentiment que l'avenir
de l'afrique peut être en europe en nous
donnant le sentiment à toute cette
jeunesse africaine que au mépris des
pires dangers
en faisant le choix du déracinement
en étant parfois instrumentalisée par
les passeurs ils trouveront de l'autre
côté de la méditerranée un eldorado qui
n'existent pas parce que nos capacités
d'intégration ne le permettent plus la
vraie générosité n'est pas celle là la
vraie générosité c'est celle qui
consiste à dire l'avenir de la jeunesse
africaine doit être en afrique
l'europe doit s'engager pour aider les
pays africains à se développer pour
faire en sorte que les capacités
d'enseignement se développe en afrique
pour faire en sorte que le continent
africain connaissent un nouveau
dynamisme sens c'est notre
responsabilité et c'est celle ci qu'il
faut assumer et quand je vois à
l'inversé car qui franchissent
maintenant les pyrénées et qui arrive à
biarritz qui arrive le long de la côte
basque avec ces visages hagards qui
savent parfois même pas où ils sont cela
ça n'est pas la vraie générosité
c'est pour cette raison que nous voulons
protéger nos frontières il faut les
protéger grâce à l'europe en espagne en
italie en grèce
ce que marine le pen n'a absolument pas
compris et il faut également qu'il
puisse y avoir en plus de cette
protection européenne une protection
nationale et que la france ait la
possibilité de choisir qui rentre ou qui
ne rentrent pas chez elle parce que ça
n'est pas parce que l'espagne a décidé
de faire des afflux d'immigration et de
faire des afflux de régularisation
qu'ensuite ces décisions doivent
s'imposer à la france nous militons pour
qu'il y ait une double protection de nos
frontières
une protection européenne et une
protection nationale contre
l'immigration irrégulière
nous sommes la seule liste à faire cette
proposition pour qu'il y ait une
civilisation il faut ensuite qu'il y ait
des projets des projets communs et seal
nous avons fait au cours des années qui
se sont écoulées tant de mal à l'europe
c'est sans doute parce qu'on a laissé
les normes se substituer au projet et
parce que nous en france parce que nous
sommes le pays de la folie des normes
nous avons eu cette démesure de croire
que parce que nous étions plus
intelligent que les autres à chaque fois
qu'il y avait une norme
tous les autres pays prennent la norme
la moins exigeante et nous nous prenons
la norme la plus folle la france a une
lourde responsabilité parce qu'elle a
systématiquement surenchérit par rapport
aux normes européennes
retrouvons le bon sens retrouvant la
simplicité retrouvons la retenue le
politique ne doit pas tout régime hanter
le politique ne doit pas tout diriger à
l'arrivée en décourage tout ceux qui
veulent entreprendre tous ceux qui
veulent faire tous ceux qui prennent des
initiatives tout aussi bien nos
agriculteurs nos commerçants les
professions libérales et ceux qui dans
ce pays entreprennent prennent des
risques et embauche la france à laquelle
nous croyons l'europe à laquelle nous
croyons c'est l'europe du travail
l'europe de la vraie solidarité par le
travail à celle de l'assistanat l'europe
qui sait que pour aider quelqu'un il
faut l'aider à le remettre sur le chemin
du travail
et vous le savez j'ai toujours milité
pour qu'en contrepartie du rsa
nous proposions systématiquement des
heures de travail d'intérêt général
obligatoires
parce que c'est la meilleure manière
d'aider les gens et parce que ça c'est
la vraie solidarité s'être plan ne peut
pas être uniquement l'europe du
consommateur je ne veux pas
comme dessein pour notre pays pour notre
continent qu'on se retrouve juste à
pousser des caddies dans les
supermarchés où tout a été fabriqué
ailleurs j'ai beaucoup de mal à
comprendre que les chinois puissent
venir chez nous acheter des terres
achetées des entreprises copiées nos
brevets etc en revanche nous nous ne
puissions aspect aucune terre en chine
aucun vignoble en chine
aucune entreprise en chine que eux
puissent venir copier nos secrets
regarder ce que nous font le fabriquer
ensuite chez eux puis ensuite le
revendre chez nous et que nous soyons
même incapable de prendre la moindre
mesure pour dire stop
vous n'avez pas le droit de faire chez
nous ce que nous ne pouvons pas faire
chez vous eh bien oui
nous réclamons le fait de dire finie la
naïveté européenne dans le rapport avec
la chine et s'être plan ne peut pas être
l'europe où tout est à acheter
la dignité humaine n'est pas à vendre
la dignité de l'homme la dignité de la
femme n'est pas à acheter
il y a des limites que l'on doit poser
face aux progrès de la science cela
s'appelle l'éthique
cela s'appelle la morale cela s'appelle
cette conviction qui est si proprement
européenne consistant à dire que tout
n'est pas possible que l'homme ne peut
pas devenir un dieu qu'il ne peut pas
tout choisir que tout ne peut pas être
génétiquement modifiés que tout ne peut
pas être trafiquées qu'il y à aussi un
respect que nous devons avoir par
rapport à ce qui nous a été transmis que
dans cette époque où l'on parle tant de
développement durable l'homme aussi est
une espèce humaine dont il faut
respecter les règles et le mode de
reproduction et le mode de transmission
tout ne peut pas être altéré tout ne
peut pas être changé
et je respecte toutes les opinions mais
je ne veux pas qu'elle soit fait en
étant caché la tête de liste en marche a
très clairement dit qu'elle était
favorable à la gestation pour autrui
c'est à dire aux mères porteuses
c'est à dire au fait de louer le ventre
d'une femme pour que l'on puisse enfanté
un enfant est qu'à sa naissance cette
enfant soit confiée à quelqu'un d'autre
ça n'est pas conforme à ce qu'est notre
vision ça n'est pas conforme à ce que
nous voulons pour l'avenir de notre
civilisation européenne nous nous
battrons pour faire en sorte que ce ne
soit pas c'est voilà qu'ils se fassent
entendre au parlement européen
nous nous battrons pour faire et va
inscrire dans notre été la protection de
la dignité humaine et le refus de la
marchandisation du corps humain est une
civilisation enfin c'est ce qu'il ya de
plus précieux de plus fragiles
ses larmes c'est ce petit bout de
culture d'histoire qui en chacune de nos
mémoires que nous en soyons d'ailleurs
conscient ou non cette civilisation et
les mortels cette civilisation et les
fragiles
cette civilisation aujourd'hui certains
veulent l'abattre comment ne pas
comprendre que les terroristes
islamistes
parfois même ceux qui sont nés sur le
sol français sur le sol européen ceux
auxquels l'europe et la france ont tout
donné avec une immense générosité et qui
ont tourné leur armes et leurs m contre
no comment ne pas comprendre que ce
qu'ils veulent détruire c'est tout ce
qu'incarne tout à la fois la france et
l'europe
comment peut-on faire preuve d'une telle
naïveté au moment du xxème siècle quand
la république instaure la laïcité
elle demande à l'église catholique de
faire des efforts pour respecter les
règles de la laïcité et faire en sorte
que nous puissions vivre en commun et
l'église catholique accepte d'adapter
son mode de fonctionnement pour faire en
sorte que la république puisse se
construire sur le respect de chacune des
consciences et c'est les règles de la
laïcité et aujourd'hui nous acceptons
silencieusement que ces mêmes règles de
la laïcité auquel toute une
des français au début du 20e siècle
avait accepté de se soumettre soit
aujourd'hui détourné utilisé par la
propagande islamiste pour retourner
contre la france sa propre d'identité et
ses propres armes et nous ne réagissons
pas et dans le programme dans marche le
mot islamisme n'est même pas verbalisés
eh bien nous nous avons le courage et la
simplicité de le dire un des plus grands
combats qui attend l'europe demain c'est
le combat contre l'islamisme
parce que c'est en deux parties de ce
combat dans lequel se jouera l'avenir de
notre identité de notre continent et
nous le disons avec la plus grande
clarté il faut qu'il y ait un pacte
européen contre l'islamisme ce pacte
européen contre l'islamisme douanes et à
fermer toutes les mosquées salafistes
qui sont en europe parce que ces
mosquées font un travail pour propager
la haine et le refus de l'autre ce pacte
européen contre l'islamisme doit
permettre de dire que quentin imams
prêchent la haine chaque vendredi il ne
doit pas rester en europe et il doit
être reconduit à l'extérieur de nos
frontières
parce qu'il a trahi ce qu'était l'esprit
de l'europe et notre civilisation
[Applaudissements]
vous savez sur les djihadistes je me
suis rendu à mossoul
ma région un programme de soutien des
minorités chrétiennes qui sont en irak
et en syrie
j'ai vu
ce qu'était le travail de destruction
des jihadistes j'ai vu leur barbarie
dans les yeux de ces familles indique
qu'ils ont été réduits en esclavage
sexuel
j'ai vu le reflet de la barbarie des
djihadistes dans les yeux de ce père de
famille
croisé au milieu des ruines de mossoul
qui avaient perdu tous ses enfants une
famille de sept enfants massacrés par
les djihadistes parce qu'il ne
partageait pas la religion j'ai vu le
reflet de cette barbarie à l'ombre de ce
building où il faisait monter leurs
victimes avec un sac sur la tête pour
les précipiter duo et pour qu'ils
agonise
au pied du building ces jihadistes sont
des barbares et le gouvernement et le
président de la république a accepté de
faire revenir 200 jihadiste sur le sol
français
nous nous demandons une chose qui est
pourtant simple
nous demandons que l'europe prenne
l'initiative d'organiser un tribunal
européen internationale en irak que ce
tribunal international permettent de
juger en irak
les djihadistes qu'ils permettent de les
condamner en irak et qu'ils permettent
surtout qu'ils restent en irak et en
syrie là où ils ont commis leur crime et
qu'il ne revienne pas sur le sol
européen
[Applaudissements]
mais françois xavier a posé la bonne
question
il a posé la vraie question comment en
est on arrivé là
ici vous le savez et je suis sûr que
dans cette salle bien des personnes
pourraient en témoigner
l'histoire de la france et de la
république a longtemps été une
extraordinaire histoire d'intégration
je suis sûr qu ici bien des figures
pourrait se lever et témoigner de ce
qu'est leur propre parcours familial des
familles qui étaient venus au moment de
la guerre civile en france y sont les
pyrénées des familles venues du portugal
pour travailler des familles venues de
pologne du nord de la france d'italie
des familles venues du sud de la
méditerranée et qui était venu ici
d'afrique en s'inscrivant dans ce
qu'était cette grande tradition de
l'intégration française dans laquelle
celui qui vient vient pour travailler
dans laquelle celui qui vient disait à
ses enfants
à compter de ce jour ton pays c'est la
france travaille dur à l'école apprend
le français ne me fait pas honte
écoutez m fais-toi respectable en étant
respecté apprend un travail devient
l'honneur et la fierté de ta famille ça
c'est l'histoire de l'intégration
française une histoire dans laquelle on
enseignait à ceux qui venaient chez nous
ce qu'était notre histoire
ce qu'était notre tradition ce
qu'étaient nos grands hommes de lettres
parce que dans la nation française les
hommes de lettres sont des figures qui
nous dirigent et qui nous éclairent seul
pays sans doute à placer à ce point là
sa confiance dans ce qu'ils écrivent et
que cela est il devenu
comment avons nous pu inverser le devoir
d'intégration
comment avons nous pu arriver à linverse
comment avons nous pu arriver à ce stade
où nous croyons qu'à cueillir l'autre
c'est accepter que ce soit nous qui
devions
changer notre mode de vie comment avons
nous pu perdre de vue le fait que c'est
exactement le contraire qu'il faut cette
leçon ne l'avons nous pas tous ressenti
quand on a vu notre dame de france brûlé
quand notre dame à brûler tout d'un coup
tout le monde a compris que nous soyons
croyants que nous ne soyons pas que nous
soyons chrétiens ou que ne le soyons pas
cet être un bout de la france qui
brûlait et pourquoi est ce que c'était
un bout de la france qui brûlaient mais
parce que bien évidemment c'est est un
des plus beaux joyaux est une des plus
belle incarnation de tout ce qui a été
le patient travail d'édification de la
france ce travail qui si vous connaissez
parfaitement ce travail qui a amené
cette ville de bordeaux à être une des
incarnations les plus parfaites de
l'esprit français
cette ville de bordeaux fondée par des
lieutenants de jules césar crassus qui
ont fait la capitale de cette province
romaine et qui trace déjà le plan de
l'urbanisme romain cette ville de
bordeaux qui est ensuite fondé à travers
ses racines chrétiennes
une deuxième fois quand le pape vient
ici et qu'il consacre la cathédrale
saint-andré cette ville de bordeaux qui
ensuite a été l'incarnation de cette
extraordinaire esprit tout à la fois des
renaissance et des lumières qui amène la
france à faire confiance sans renier ses
racines chrétiennes dans l'esprit du
progrès et dans l'esprit de la science
et à devenir ainsi une des ville
éclairée de notre pays
cette ville qui peut s'enorgueillir
quand on parle d'un maire de dire ici
michel de montaigne et est un maire
cette ville qui peut s'enorgueillir
d'avoir vu ces deux grands esprits
français montaigne et montesquieu qui
dialoguait de part et d'autre de la
renaissance et de l'esprit des lumières
cette ville de bordeaux qui a eu
l'audace de partir à la conquête du
monde est aujourd'hui dans une époque où
il paraît qu'il ne faut plus cités
colbert
et qu'il faut bannir les bustes de
colbert mais quelle profonde erreur de
juger les temps passés à l'aune de nos
idées d'aujourd'hui
oui on peut être fier de ce qu'ont fait
les bordelais quand ils sont partis à la
conquête du monde
oui ils ont à l'époque fait preuve
d'audace et ils ont construit les bases
de ce qu'était le rayonnement de
bordeaux et une partie de la fierté
française que des erreurs ont été
commises bien sûr mais qu'il faille
ensuite donné cette image terrible où la
france ne cesse de s'excuser de son
histoire
au lieu d'en transmettre la fierté et la
reconnaissance aux générations
d'aujourd'hui quel profonde erreur soyez
fiers de bordeaux soyez fiers de vos
industries conquérante soyez fiers des
nouvelles technologies d'aujourd'hui et
soyez fiers de vos racines soyez fier de
tout ce que vous incarnez soyez fiers de
ce territoire de nouvelles aquitaine et
bien la leçon de notre dame de france
est ce là il y à des incendies visible
et il y à des incendies invisible une
civilisation peut partir à travers ses
monuments et elle peut partir quand on
renonce quand on se soumet et quand on
recule
à chaque fois qu'on renonce à enseigner
notre histoire de france à nos enfants
dans nos classes c'est un incendie à
chaque fois que l'on accepte que dans un
quartier une femme ne puissent plus
choisir son destin professionnel ou la
façon dont elle veut se vêtir 7
un incendie à chaque fois que nous
renonçons à une petite parcelle de ce
que nous sommes
7 un incendie pourquoi je n'ai jamais
voulu reculer sur cette question en
apparence si anodine des crèches
parce que je suis convaincu que les
crèches est un petit bout de ce que nous
sommes et parce qu'à chaque fois qu'on
recule même sur un petit bout infime de
ce que nous sommes c'est un bout de
notre civilisation que l'empoignade et
cambrai saba alors oui mes amis soyez
fiers de cette histoire en france
l'histoire c'est tout à la fois quelque
chose dont on peut être fier et dont on
doit être digne
soyons fiers de notre histoire et
rappelons cette belle leçon de
saint-augustin à rome fais comme les
romains en france en europe ça n'est pas
à nous de nous adapter à celui qui vient
de l'être
gc ca lutte c'est à celui qui vient de
l'étranger de s'adapter à ce qu'est le
mode de vie du pays et du continent qui
l'a choisi c'est cette fierté que nous
voulons retrouver
c'est cette refondation de l'europe que
nous voulons retrouver
c'est ce rétablissement de la france que
nous voulons retrouver françois xavier a
besoin de vous il a besoin de vous pour
nous aider à transformer cet espoir en
un mouvement qui ne s'arrêtera pas il a
besoin de vous pour faire en sorte que
dans cette campagne des européennes nous
puissions à nouveau faire entendre les
valeurs et les convictions qui sont les
nôtres il nous reste huit jours
il vous reste huit jours pour nous aider
à convaincre
il vous reste huit jours pour faire le
choix des convictions il vous reste huit
jours pour montrer oui que dans cette
campagne on élimine parmi eux ont choisi
par rapport à ce qu'on veut il vous
reste huit jours pour mener le plus beau
des combats
je n'en connais pas de plus beau en
france je n'en connais pas de plus beau
en europe
c'est le combat de l'identité c'est le
combat de la civilisation c'est le
combat qui consiste à refonder l'europe
et à rétablir la france vivra et livre
la france
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]